Yeah.
Don't make a strain with nothing for trinity.
Queens broke man,
tinge it Kelly.
Mel told the drill in the beauty chemo.
Those were the days I remember we used to be closed and I was not cold.
This went,
I remember slipping in December,
two feet of snow kit as the east coast at black ice civilize the rat bite that
was slick is fully understood.
I had to come from the Hood Doing The pee wee Herman the smurf before the phones
truck.
The black truck slower,
didn't happy all works.
Thought he was the former belly levels.
That was whatever hip hop forever kept my Brady Yo one 98 of BLS had a pre
pubescent liberty gift when Niggas never hit me spit.
My little brother tried to warn him I was a tornado coming from inside like the
office storm and Toma pops about it.
He gave us tickets to that whilst down flick.
Double trouble with charter,
which was the proudest,
I've never had a summer job.
Sweeping leads,
socks to my knees.
Homing shorts cutoff.
Lee's I work a day in my bike's wiping away your brace.
The off the paper,
man.
I'm just trying to say ranch big radio takes slowing down mode where the lights
go bad or be dead.
I've got a freeze them today.
Ice Cold in the freezer.
Leda of staring at the speaker so I can have eight olds deeper clean in my
sneakers with the bristles up with two crusts,
so more on the tissue string.
Soper,
Lord,
I
ain't got nothing to do with Bowles school.
New School don't.
South West Coast,
east coast.
This will allow us to south things in our San is cave.
Is that NAS?
Yeah.
Nas versus Justice Mashup.
This is our thing.
Nope.
Who's got some of my favorite lyrics?
Nice.
Yeah,
that backward saw shit.
I like the backwards songs.
The cleverest,
you know,
he's like a guy.
It'll you know.
You've been some lyrics that just make you go,
whoa.
Didn't expect that.
Totally.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the podcast.
We started off in a very strange five today.
Is that me chewing gum or is that you chewing gum?
No one was chewing gum by the way last week.
We apologize.
It was Eliza slash jurors dog and her sweet little dog.
We wanted to chill the dog out,
so he gave the dog this little raw hide toy and a homeboy was going to work
while the podcast,
what's going on?
And it sounded like someone snapping gum.
That's not what it was.
Yeah,
we're sorry about that shit was just a dark.
If it's a dog,
isn't it?
A little bit less annoying and it's totally annoying.
Well,
no,
it's less than less than knowing about it's yeah,
because if it's a person like,
oh,
assholes,
just chewing his fucking gum.
That's so rude.
So it wasn't like people were being rude to you were just being to a dog.
Just imagine the sounds of a fleshlight and it's so much better just being used.
That's worse than a dog.
No,
this is worse than a dog.
Brian.
Fuck is wrong with you.
Not for the ladies.
The ladies would like to think that more than adults showing probably.
All I'm trying to say is no one was chewing gum.
I'll try to say,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Brendan Walsh,
please welcome Brendan Walsh to the podcast.
Hi everybody.
Fresh at a Texas bitches fresh out at fucking Austin.
Austin,
Texas is such a strange place,
man.
Just one like super hippie spot in the middle of this really conservative kind
of fucking,
you know,
drag black guys behind trucks.
Yeah.
Lot of that shit going on outside of that,
you know,
I mean,
I love Dallas and I love Houston and I loved the cities in Texas,
but like there's a big difference between Austin and ally
and everywhere else.
Like in even he,
I'd say Houston,
but like any,
like Houston has a cool part of their town.
There's like a little part of the city that's,
that's kind of okay,
but any other place,
like just imagine for a second living in Dallas,
like,
yeah.
Or any other place in Texas at Austin is just so different for,
not just for the state.
I mean,
for the country.
It's like,
it's a unique,
cool place to live.
It's a weird vibe,
right?
It's really always fascinated me.
Um,
w w w when,
when towns like get a vibe like San Francisco in the 60s I would've loved to
have seen what that was like.
Oh,
I think about that a lot.
do you?
Yeah.
Like documentaries on it.
That must have been so strange before acid was illegal and yeah,
I watched the,
um,
the end of hair last night,
uh,
you know,
the movie hair and just the last scene I was hanging out with my friend Henry
Phillips.
Do you know Henry?
Yes.
Um,
and yeah,
I dunno.
He showed musician guy.
Yeah.
Music.
He's not played with Doug.
Yeah.
He played on Dosey.
Um,
something to take the edge off.
So one of my favorite one.
Yeah,
it's a great one.
It isn't.
He did it very rhythmically together.
They work great,
you know?
Yeah.
It's funny when Doug,
and this is obviously,
you know,
second hand,
but,
uh,
I've heard it from both of them.
When they first started hanging out,
like Doug Knew Henry was a guitar comic and didn't see as act for years because
he was afraid.
He was like,
well,
if I see her act,
it's guitar comedy,
it's going to suck.
I want to be friends with you anymore.
And,
uh,
but then when he say Henry's hilarious.
I mean,
I dunno if you're familiar with his stuff,
but uh,
I'm not too familiar with it,
but that is a funny thing man.
It's really hard to be friendly with someone who's not funny.
Yeah.
And they were,
yeah,
they were crawling around a lot.
So Doug was like,
I don't even want to see it.
That's funny.
Yeah.
But Henry's great.
He actually,
while we were talking in the car,
he has a movie called punching a clown that he made.
It's hilarious.
And it's uh,
it's how you can get it on Netflix or whatever.
Do they have a Netflix streaming?
I don't think on streaming
dam,
but uh,
but it's definitely,
you know,
word by copying.
Yeah.
By the way,
before we get started,
I don't have anything invested in the movie.
I have to thank our sponsor.
The fleshlight is,
it is an actual sponsor.
Yeah,
I've heard that too.
Don't put the rubber Dick on him.
He always creeping people out with the rubber Dick.
They made a rubber duck,
but no one's,
fuck this.
You don't have to worry about it.
But check it out.
If you've ever felt one of these things before,
uh,
no,
fill it.
That's like some serious tech that's supposed to be a butthole,
some serious technology man.
Yeah.
That's pretty weird.
I mean this is Dave.
Dave figured out masturbation.
They got that shit nailed.
Yeah,
that's pretty fucking sporty.
It's great if they just keep making these,
I think the evolution of the masturbatory devices over,
I mean this is good and enough.
Yeah.
I know.
Maybe some sort of a self self cleaning jammy might be pretty good.
Iphone charging dock.
Hey,
I phone on Verizon today.
Yes.
Did you hear about that?
Good.
Five phones coming out on Verizon.
Oh,
I heard something last night.
The only thing that sucks is it's not international.
So like if you go somewhere,
like if you go to England,
tried to use it.
It's not gonna work.
And indeed an invoice.
Yeah,
you can't use,
but you know.
And how often does that come up is I come up for you a yeah.
Hey,
I'm on the phone.
you want to go get something to eat tonight?
Yeah.
Hold on.
Let me look online and find out a good ref.
Oh,
and you do it right while you're talking,
huh?
And you do it right while you're talking.
You do on a t and T.
Oh,
I do it all the time.
Or you're like talking to somebody listened to Pandora or something.
Well,
on one hand,
can you just hang up the phone on the other hand,
that is kind of cool to be able to do that.
Yeah.
Do you use a headset or something?
Well,
a car Bluetooth you.
Oh,
right,
right.
You're driving while you're doing this.
No,
like,
like at a suck.
Complicated.
The texting you fuck,
you're out there risking lives like stop lights installed.
Only it's top ones.
Yeah.
You got to discipline yourself son.
Dude in the traffic out here is a little bit different than most places.
Most of the time you're sitting here going two miles an hour,
you know it's still,
it's dangerous texting.
You can go two miles an hour.
Dangerous Fred Lights.
You didn't see it in time spying.
You like you don't do it at all?
No,
I don't allow myself to because I'm worried about hitting somebody,
man.
I'm worried about being irresponsible.
Definitely when you're on the highway going 55 miles an hour,
I'm not just doing it.
I just won't look at it.
You know?
I'll take phone calls and I can make phone calls with my,
my car makes,
you know,
does Bluetooth so you can actually tell it to depress,
press a button and say call Brian and just talk through your stereo.
Yeah,
that'll do.
But I'm not fucking texting.
That's crazy.
I've seen people do it.
I've,
I've had people do it while they were driving and I was a pastor and I asked him
to stop.
I'm like,
man,
you can't do that.
That's,
that's too crazy.
Like that's like you're,
you're,
you're like riding a motorcycle on one leg.
Right?
You might get away with it,
but this shit might end to ugly man.
Put the fucking phone down.
You're typing with two hands and controlling the steering wheel with your
pinkies.
It's a 2000 pound piece of machinery at your time.
As more like for new designs,
like a race car.
That's like a stripped down car with licensing.
I don't know how much cars with 4,000 now do all that to miles per hour.
You could probably do it right way and that's what you need.
Allow the traffic in La.
I hear you man.
I just,
when I'm in my car,
so something,
there's a guy named Tony Vee from Boston and he taught me this and he was,
he was a comic comic from Boston,
excuse me.
And he was traveling from Boston to New York a lot.
He was driving like,
who's going like all the time,
like a couple of times a week,
you know,
it's like,
what's he doing?
Half hours?
Oh,
the Aaron back.
And he was going back and forth and back and forth and I,
and I said,
doesn't that drive you crazy?
Like how do you not go nuts when you're fucking drive?
And he goes,
well,
you know what?
The way I look at it,
I get in the car,
I just goes,
then I say,
this is what I'm doing now.
I'm driving my car.
It's like,
I'm not going to freak out about it because I'm just going to keep doing it and
do it all the time.
Just it's all in how you approach it.
And I went,
wow,
that's such a fucking smart way of looking at it.
And I,
it like forced me to rewire the way I look at certain things.
You know,
like bull shit,
that's boring.
Travel,
air travel,
you know,
you can really bum yourself out and going,
fuck,
I'm getting a fucking point and you just know what's ahead of you and just get
zen.
Just [inaudible]
kind of attitude with the driving.
I drove a lot when I first started,
you know,
doing the road and um,
I had driven from Austin to la or San Diego a bunch of times and that's like a
20 hour drive and I would just do it,
you know,
drive,
do it straight through most of the time.
Um,
but it's just like,
you know,
it's like,
all right,
well I'm going to be in the car for a couple days.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I just want to get there.
I mean,
I'm a fucking,
I'm an animal behind the wheel.
Do you worry about the whole fucking speeding aside?
I don't,
I don't speed like crazy.
No,
I'll do like just right around 10 miles over the limit.
Just done their crazy.
There's like a little gambling thing you do.
There is,
you see people with past you and you're doing that and it's like,
well that guy's doing a fucking hundreds.
So like nobody's going to pull me over here.
Certain people on the highway just go,
this guy should not be driving man.
How many times you've been in the hind when you see some dude just weaving in
and out of traffic with that need for speed bag bag.
You know,
inside that guy's car is pride.
Sounds like Wu,
like he's probably one of those like guy that prints out his card that like,
you know,
like need for speed drifting.
He probably drifts around zip a lot.
Sometimes it's just douche bags,
man.
Well it's people.
Everybody's the most important fucking thing in the world.
Like,
like when you see cars fucking parked in parking lots and they're not like when
people totally crossover to spaces like real assholes.
But like
if they're like kind of not between the lines,
right.
It's like what are you in such a hurry for?
Like I always straighten my car out and fucking make sure you're not going to
fucking
the point.
Is this like the most boring conversation line though?
There's this fine line between being a courteous driver in getting stuck behind
a monkey.
Yeah.
You know,
sometimes you just see some dude,
you're like all these fucking dummy,
you don't even know what you're doing dummy.
You're fucking panicking.
You're locking up the street.
Okay.
Do I go around this guy?
Fuck Ya.
Just go.
Yeah.
No.
Sometimes you have to make that move to cause otherwise it just be back there
going really it's just took 10 minutes longer cause you're retarded.
I gotta be behind you.
You fuck.
That's why there needs to be something that feature where you can just shoot
that guy like a text message using his license plate number or something like,
like fuck you.
I hate you.
Speed.
Here's my ball.
Ideally,
Brian,
the utopia would be that they would no longer exist and we would use robots,
right.
Targeted to blame.
Those people wouldn't exist anymore.
We would have a fully enlightened society.
We would be able to really go into the ghettos and revive the school systems
there cause we wouldn't be afraid of having poor people around all the time.
Kill them off now.
We would be fine,
man.
We'd be utopia.
We wouldn't be afraid anymore.
That's the idea,
Brian.
I know.
Not supposed to shoot them text messages.
That's shit's not going to help.
Their stupid.
Well we've got to do is stop making stupid people.
We've got to help those people not be stupid.
Therefore their children won't be stupid and there'll be no more stupid people.
That shit is all possible.
Yeah.
Are we just think,
well,
I mean it's already possible,
but metal dude though.
The genetic dude where you go like this guy,
no matter what,
this is that guy,
he's fucked.
He's just working on three cells of a nine cell battery.
He's just,
he just doesn't,
it's not all there.
He's not that.
There's not much going on up there.
There's a lot of people that are just like that.
Like you have to,
some guys have big Dick sometimes.
Some guys do not.
Some guys have super powerful brains,
I'm guys do not.
Some guys have brains that suck.
You know?
That's an unfortunate part of life and it's not even that you're,
you'll have down syndrome where you have a disease.
You're just Donald.
Some Jack has,
there's a spectrum.
Unfortunately there's a biological spectrum of people and it includes brains,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean you need kind of like,
we need some people to deliver pizzas and filled potholes there.
Almost two right now.
Right now you do.
Until we figure out how to make robots that can do everything,
then you don't need people anymore.
Now need people doing any nonsense things.
You just need robot repair people.
That's all you need.
Right?
I can't wait for that repair guys.
That'll be every like when you're watching Maury Povich the see those
commercials for like a robot repair call.
I had this joke that I used to do about the two things you'll never see the same
time is marijuana being legal and jet packs because society would crumble
because there would be no work if he had jet packs and you'd have to,
you know like you have to break things down.
It's very important.
You don't have too much fun.
You want to keep society rolling.
Brian will tell you that.
Right?
Brian's right.
Brian's just 100% fun.
I am fun.
So this iPhone,
the problem is you're not going to be able to do calls and get online at the
same time.
She won't be able to do that.
To me that's a pretty big deal for me.
I'm a very data,
very multitasking iPhone user and at least I want that option where Tiffany,
I have Verizon and I have a palm pre plus and it's great.
But yeah,
I mean I've,
I've noticed,
you know,
doing,
trying to do things on that.
You know when I'm on the phone and the iPhone on the t eight t and t was the
ship,
the iPhone would be the greatest thing ever.
But 18 cheese just sucks.
It's so hard.
Yeah.
It's going to be so much nicer.
I don't have an iPhone,
but I don't know anybody who can get reception anywhere,
like where they live.
Like my old,
this is what happens man.
When we have a UFC,
there's like 18,000 people in the arena.
Yeah.
Before anyone's there.
I can use my iPhone,
I can get online and go on my Twitter can check things out,
but when as soon as the arena fills up,
it's dead.
It's useless.
You can't get along.
I tried to Twitter what from my phone like,
like when things happen in between rounds,
I can't do it now.
Imagine half of that arena if not more,
leaving that arena to go to the Verizons arena and then your,
your cell phone would work better,
right?
Yeah.
That's what the biggest problem is,
is overcrowding on towers and the hands.
Do you think that that's going to happen the same way with Verizon is at the
same sort of a system because how much I think it's good.
I think it's going to dilute the cell phones coverage out completely.
You know?
It's going,
it's not going to be everyone on 18 t just so they can have an iPhone.
It's going to be kind of more,
you know,
diluted.
Right.
But what I'm saying is do you think that Verizon is going to get over burdened?
Can they have first capacity at first?
I bet yes.
There's going to be a lot of problems.
So we just,
I bet you'll watch Verizon's network deteriorate at least for in the first
couple of months during,
uh,
during south by southwest a couple years ago,
nobody's,
I worked in the whole town,
Boston cause 150,000 hipsters all with iPhones come to town where there's all
right and you just couldn't get ahold of anybody and that so ridiculous.
You guys were forced at south by southwest to go like caveman.
So I have Timo,
you're fine.
Yeah,
I have a,
I have a blackberry,
but I couldn't get ahold of anyone.
I used to have a 18 t blackberry and I thought,
you know,
this is just the way waste coverages.
And then I got a Verizon one and driving around La,
like all the spots that he used to drop off.
It doesn't drop off though.
Yeah.
That to me is fucking gigantic.
That's the most important thing I gotta be able to talk to,
going to be able to talk to and I can't talk to you.
And if the phone cuts out,
that's number one to me.
Yeah,
I phones are way better than blackberries,
but for me it's most important things.
I got to be able to definitely know that I can get ahold of you,
that I can get a get a signal that's annoying as fuck to me when there's a lot
of dead zones when you can't keep an important conversation when you're driving
somewhere,
but you still have to have an important conversation.
I can have those conversations in my car with Verizon,
but all those problems are 90 a lot of it is from overcrowding,
the cell phone towers.
Is that true?
Because what I heard is that GSM has a harder time switching towers.
Well,
it would be true if that if you drove the same place every single day and it
happened at the exact same place while you're on the phone every single time it
does to me,
it happens to me.
There's there,
to me,
there's one place that I know of where you just go down this little loop and you
lose service
for a second and that's the only place I can let I remember every single time.
But other than that,
it's so random from from me driving to legends drive it to the Jujitsu Gym.
Right.
There's a few places where it just always cuts out every single time.
Yeah.
But with Verizon it doesn't
boring as fuck in conversations is pretty cool.
It's like a couple of guys hanging out on their break fucking loading dock,
techno version talk.
What's amazing is how many people who are all like on Verizon or an on ATNT want
you to be on it too.
You know those assholes like,
come on man.
Get with sprint bro.
Look at this.
I got this phone man.
It's good.
It's good for minutes though.
If you know like you have minute to minute calls
rollover Mindy and it's true and stuff like that.
That's true.
You could look at it.
I mean that's a smart way of looking at it,
right?
Some people want to be on the same team as you.
Yeah.
When you have at and t,
if you don't use like 50 minutes the next month,
do you keep that 50 minutes and then it's onto your minute collection and you
can collect them.
You know I just have unlimited,
right?
Yeah.
You can do that too,
which is you're paying probably extra than you really need to.
I guess.
If you looked,
let me throw my hat into the ring here.
T-Mobile,
it's like a stripper strugglers all have that.
You really don't.
I prefer number all.
Fuck yeah,
that's a stir.
But that's like,
Hey,
I only works everywhere.
Got Cricket.
Wait,
so like now I got cricket.
Wha what is,
what is t mobile like fucking skank phone.
It is a weird one.
It's a weird one.
Yeah.
Horizon is,
you're a a,
you know,
no nonsense person.
That's like an okay to lose the signal.
That's coke and Pepsi and you're drinking RC.
Got It.
So you don't even have the iPhone and you got this shitty service or no,
it's good.
I don't have any t mobile's no problems.
I know where,
yeah,
like it all.
It always works and it's like I don't pay that much.
No,
no.
I actually would go with t mobile before there was spring.
Probably my touch.
It's like basically the iPhone.
Yeah.
Keep telling yourself that probably got a bunch of Apis to radio shack version
of Atari or something that'd have been close.
See iPhone five years ago.
Check this out.
Look.
Well,
this is an older model.
That fucking phone is.
That's,
that's the,
that really is like some crazy leap of technology.
I never thought it was at first,
but then I realized as time went on,
when you start dealing with the applications,
then you realize like,
Whoa,
this is like the most insane little device ever.
Yeah.
This is not just a phone.
I can hold this fucking thing up to a speaker and it'll tell me what the song
is.
And also like,
I just put,
I know like way ghetto,
I just discovered the,
well angry birds,
you know,
that fucking video game?
No,
no.
But like I was,
yeah,
I've,
I'm,
whatever.
I just,
I never fuck with that shit.
And somebody showed it to me recently,
I was like,
oh,
this is fun.
But
the fact that like,
you pull the bird back with your screen,
like,
just the fact that it's like this thing knows like how far and how hard to pull
this like rubber band.
Like how do they know where that is on the screen and it's alien technology,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
you know,
at a certain point in time,
people look at things and they just go,
how did this ever get thought up?
You know,
and really does seem like it's alien ship.
It's gotta be something.
Because how did we make the leap from,
like,
when I was a kid,
there were fucking rotary phones and then now there's this,
I'm 37 and like,
I was using rotary phones and like,
you know,
uh,
we,
we didn't have a microwave.
It's like if you wanted to make a potato when I was like eight years old,
you'd have to block out like 40 minutes and make a fucking potato.
Right.
I have to fucking fake that shit.
Yeah,
and when like microwaves were just like,
oh,
here's this new thing and I don't know
for that.
I remember that.
Of course,
you know when I was,
I'm,
I'm 43 when I was a kid,
there was no little self.
There was no answering machines.
Rather even you couldn't even get ahold of somebody if you just,
you got a call when it was like an emergency or you're trying to call it radio
station you're trying to do to rotate rotary dial and you're like,
hey,
you're like trying to force it to go faster.
How crazy is caller id?
The first time I saw caller id I was like,
whoa.
They can tell you who's calling like a little digital readout.
It's like a separate standalone device.
It would read the number as it was calling in.
Would it say it out loud?
Call from three to three one,
one six and you're like,
whoa.
We are in the fucking future.
I had when I was in Austin when everybody was getting the the caller id boxes,
I guess,
I don't know if I had to change the number into my name or something.
Either way I got,
I found out you could get listed as whatever you want in the white pages.
So I told him my name was Guy Chinese.
So every time when I called on my friends it just,
it's a Chinese guy,
some Chinese guy called cause it does last name first.
Right.
And uh,
yeah that's just,
that's something I was reminded of recently
when you look at the phone,
when,
when an iPhone,
like when you get a phone call and it's coming in and you see that full
resolution photo of the person.
Oh yeah,
let me see their name over it.
It's like,
I don't think we realize how fucking crazy that idea really is.
The idea that you're able to send photos and images to each other for stream
video,
but touchscreen is like,
yeah,
that was my mom.
Like I don't,
how does that iPad for,
how does that Shit fucking work?
And how did that just happen?
All of a sudden an
exponential,
you know,
advances in technologies.
Like one guy figures out one thing that applies to something else and they all
get in together and then they come up with a better one and then it builds from
there.
And there's so many fucking people working on this shit all over the world.
I mean,
and w you know,
technology begets better technology.
It just keeps going and going and going and going.
And it's at a fever pitch for,
I got an apple
TV and I don't know if you've seen this,
this little blue little box that you hook up to your TV and it's already okay,
I fucking love it.
And like,
and I have an Xbox,
I have a ps three of all that shit.
But this thing is so perfect.
And what's cool about it with your iPhone,
like if you're sitting there and you want to search for a movie on Netflix or
iTunes or something like that,
you just connect it with the remote application and just sit there and use your
iPhone as like the best remote ever.
It's perfect.
So you can use it,
uh,
you can connect to like this slide shows what's cool.
If you have a flicker,
your iPhone connects as a wireless remote.
Right.
And if you have any videos or photos or anything on your phone,
you just press play and it will transfer it to your TV and your sound system.
So like I was watching like videos I've filmed and just transferred it to my,
and you're watching it on TV?
Yeah,
from my oven or,
or I wanted to use my iTunes on here,
so I transferred it to holy Shit,
like wireless and share other computers.
My old roommate had the,
yeah.
And uh,
I could,
yeah,
there's a setting in and I could play all my iTunes and shit through the TV,
through the TV.
And what's also cool is that a,
if you have a flicker account,
it connects to your photos and you can do like the last 200 photos.
So I have like,
if you've ever been in my flicker,
just random photos and it makes like these cool collages as like a screensaver
while you're listening to music.
So it's just like this tripped out slideshow from all your last 200 flickers and
it's,
it's crazy.
Like there's pictures of you and then there's pictures of like,
you know like Jody as balls and just mixed into like this collage.
It's bad ass and you can do it to anybody.
So I could do it two years.
Like I can type in a,
yeah,
at Joe's flicker account.
So then it does a slideshow of all your photos.
Like are your last 200 bad ass.
What the fuck is going on?
Love it.
I don't know.
I'm still upset.
You guys told me I have a Dorky,
a cell phone charger.
Not,
no.
I mean it is a park.
That fellow,
you're going to be fun.
It is a fair fee.
You actually do have a track ball on it.
I know.
Gotta realize balls are so 2000 so I'm really,
I'm so not a technology guy.
Like I don't,
I don't know.
I don't feel the need.
Like when new shit comes out,
I know you're like,
yeah,
I didn't know it and I just,
I don't know.
I can like,
this is crazy.
That's like fuck,
I don't even like do you drink scholastically?
You're rendering Scott,
you're much more logical.
I mean realistically just stay,
you don't pay attention as much.
Stay a bit behind the curve and just to fucking,
it's plenty.
Yeah.
And then people who are like,
who get all the new shit,
they'll be like,
oh wait,
you don't have an iPod?
I'll give you one here,
take this.
You know?
And you're like,
oh cool.
And then I have like a first edition Ipod,
but it's the coolest thing I ever own.
That's awesome.
You're completely true.
Because I give all my shit away to like,
like my friends like Duncan Duncan has got like a whole entertainment system was
just like old printers and oh wow.
LCD screens.
And Duncan's got my old iPhone.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh that's right.
He was talking about that the other night.
They,
him and Natasha just moved in up the street from me.
So hanging out Ford your,
that's
right.
We're already working it out free.
Go get your freak on.
Me and Dunkin are gonna Double Team Natasha get mayor.
Qt involved in isn't a beautiful,
that you work with comedians and you can say things like that.
No one gets upset.
So we'll see.
We'll see.
But this is,
if this was a,
you know,
a group of plumbers at some sort of talk about double teaming,
someone's wife,
not really,
not really that funny,
but comedians where,
you know,
he just accept it for the front of most part.
Well,
first of all,
you know when to say it and how to say it.
Right.
You know,
but there's a lot of people that aren't comics that was,
say it,
and you'd be pissed probably in the drama back.
And I just that to your,
what about your wife?
And you're be like,
what?
Well,
you gotta talk about banking,
someone's wife,
you've got to really know him.
Good.
Yeah.
He can't just fucking,
you know,
crack jokes about that to some guy who don't know,
it's gotta be after,
you know,
I've been around you and the wife for 10 years and you haven't tried to fuck her
yet.
Right.
You could be some crazy person.
Yeah.
Cracking jokes and making everybody uncomfortable.
I always think it's weird when you find out like somebody that you think you
are,
that you do know fairly well,
and then you touch on something weird where it's just an innocuous joke about
like,
oh,
I heard your mom has big tits or whatever,
and you're like,
hey,
fucking,
no,
I'm not down with that mom shit.
You're like,
Whoa,
wait what?
You're rational about every other thing.
But then there's like this weird line that can be crossed.
Yeah.
Well there's people that are looking for you to cross a line all the time too.
Oh yeah.
Fucking outta line,
bro.
There's those Adeline guys that are looking to say that it's unacceptable.
Yeah.
Did you see that documentary about bank ski or Banksy Banksy exit through the
gift Shag exited a gift shop?
No,
I didn't.
I saw the preview and it didn't compel me.
It's a pretty interesting,
it's good though.
It's good.
It's fun.
It's one of those things that you're going to look at at least la a little bit
different now.
Like,
like there's so many things that you just don't even notice like that Andre the
giant,
a symbol that's everywhere.
It shows the guy that makes that and what he does and how he's been doing and
he's been doing it through,
you know,
everywhere.
And it just shows also like all these street work.
When the guy does that comes out and says that,
can't they arrest him?
Um,
I mean because they consider that like when you put those images all over the
place like that,
they consider that they probably could.
I probably could handle ism say,
but maybe unless they catch you red handed,
like you could go around all day and say,
yeah,
I put that up there.
But really if there's no roof,
I mean,
how are they going to prove that you did it?
What your second session,
if you're an artist,
here's your work.
Where's,
here's this first original sketches.
Yeah,
I did.
Um,
I put myself on a billboard in silver lake.
I was driving home from the airport and I saw there was a top chef,
the new season for top chef,
like last season was in Washington DC and they had all the contestants standing
in like the reflecting pool at the Washington monument on this billboard.
And when I was driving past that,
I just thought like,
it'd be funny as shit if there was just some other,
if you just added another cast member,
some weird dude and I had just seen that exit through the gift shop and you
know,
they get these big things printed up real big.
It can't goes.
I was like,
oh I can get it printed up.
And I called and was like,
they do adhesive vinyl at Kinko's.
He make it as big as you want.
So I put on,
I put on like a fedora and a chef's shirt like everyone else was wearing.
It had a big pot and was like stirring it.
I had my friend take a picture and I had to print it up real big at Kinko's.
And then,
um,
and then I rented a ladder from Home Depot and climbed up on the roof of the
seven 11 and fucking stuck myself.
If I could email it to you.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I have some fun.
But the thing is I,
my guy is like half the size.
I'm way smaller than them.
I,
well one of them I miss,
uh,
I caught,
well,
I uh,
I missed judge.
I did misjudged the size of the billboard slyly but I did want myself to be
smaller because I was going to put myself,
like I was in the background of the reflecting pool.
I can be a pot,
but when I got up there I couldn't reach up high enough.
So it's just like the cast of people.
Did you worry about falling?
No,
it was on the roof of a seven 11.
So I just had to get up onto the roof and then use another like an eight foot
ladder to get up to the board.
Dude,
that's so cool.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
I can pull it up on,
no,
you get in trouble for this though.
We should,
we not told it's done.
It's over.
Like they took the billboard down.
Right.
But it was somebody else's ad.
Well you know what I want to,
I was at a party and there was an executive producer for the show who heard
about it and thought it was hilarious.
Well,
so they,
they gave the green light.
I have to get it out of my email.
No,
well they just,
I mean it was already there.
Yeah.
I mean it's not like you're ruining it.
[inaudible] it's so creative,
you know,
it was pretty fun.
That's a genius.
And um,
yeah,
I guess I can't,
I won't sell out the people who helped me,
but,
uh,
me and the guy too was like my lookout.
Like I had a guy on the corner just to see,
cause it was at a busy intersection and just,
he was,
I had my headphones on with my cell phone.
He was just over there,
just like,
all right,
there's no cops,
no car.
Like he was just there to tell me if cops were coming.
Um,
but we both,
like after we did it,
we both agreed.
Like I haven't felt that kind of like excitement.
It was like it was a feeling that I haven't really felt since like 15 or 16 but
just real mischief like oh my kid cotton.
Right.
I don't know.
There was a certain like cause we weren't like drunk or high or like there was a
certain kind of innocence and like fucking Oh man,
I haven't felt like that in a while.
Like that was like,
cause like if you get caught too,
like what's going to happen?
The Co like especially you're sober,
you're not high and the cop's like what are you doing right?
You're like well I just,
yeah I know.
I just put my picture on there.
That's,
I don't know.
You know,
I'm a fucking idiot.
I guess.
What are you,
what that right.
Let's get this over with like,
cause if you're not wasted or anything right then what do they get you with to
get you with private vandalism?
Like wait,
you're pretty sure I talked to my friends in that it's pretty serious.
If it crossed a lot of money to fix well board,
it's not like people that have sprays like sprayed the side of buildings and it
costs a lot to repair and she has like,
it can be really expensive yet.
Well I think there's a,
the big difference between graffiti I guess and like what like bank scaler and
then all these like street artists,
guys,
these guys are actually making like pieces of art that are okay better with the
graffiti guys.
Do some patchwork.
But you know,
these guys do some stuff that where people want that graffiti so bad,
they'll buy the wall of that building and for millions of dollars,
you know,
I mean that's how big these guys,
his art and the cool thing about this movie is that it shows how they
do that.
How they sell you the wall of a building.
Uh,
they would loosen adopting a highway thing.
So we're going to take this fucking building and they'll take the wall off or a
piece that,
of that part of the building.
Wow.
Yeah.
This is a,
I've never even heard of that.
Yeah.
What this,
watch his documentary.
That's a billboard that I never got to a or that's the thing I was going to put
on the billboard within 10 foot by four foot wieners sticker.
Uh,
there were these ads for,
I don't know what it was like urgent care or something and the whole billboard
is just the blue billboard with white writing and that like font that said my
blank hurts my blank liners.
So we're going to put,
we're going to fill it in with,
yes.
They're just said billboards in time.
Winner hurts.
It was in November and like I was on the road and I got back and saw either way
I saw the billboard was like,
let's do that.
It was like that time,
it was like mid November.
It rained for like two weeks almost every night it rained so we couldn't do it
cause it's a big stick or we couldn't do it when it was raining.
We didn't want to do it on a Friday or Saturday because it was a busy kind of,
there was a bar right there.
Right.
Either way,
the night when we were finally,
it wasn't raining.
We were going to do it.
They took the billboard down.
We missed it by literally a few hours.
Can't you just find like a switch and eager billboard?
There's no more than a million or something.
Well yeah,
I mean we have the sticker.
You could put wieners somewhere else.
Well I can also just spray paint over it and make it into something I like.
I've been keeping my eyes out and easy to access billboards.
Yeah,
you should put it on like,
like you know,
like I don't know.
Or Wiener abortion clinic,
a billboard or something.
We'll see.
Wavy.
You've seen a board.
I could planned parenthood.
We're like,
oh my gosh,
look at
abortion clinics.
Or how about make the planned parenthood one wear to like the woman's looking
down at her belly.
You know something about,
yes.
Don't
be Scott Wiener on her stomach or something.
Yeah,
I don't know.
Well I just,
I've been thinking of like,
Oh I need to find a use for the winner sticker.
But it's like I can just paint over it like you can still.
So now I'm looking to see,
cause it's 10 feet by four feet.
That's a lot of vinyl.
That's fun.
Next time you do that,
let me videotape it.
Okay.
That'd be hilarious.
Guys are both going to jail.
I'll do it.
Anyway.
This documentary,
it's,
here's the important part about it.
It's about this,
uh,
what's made an exit through the gift shop.
Yeah.
It's this camera guy.
He fucking is this crazy French guy that just tapes everything and he has boxes
and boxes and boxes and boxes of tapes,
you know,
of mini DV tapes.
And then one day he was like,
Borden is,
he was like,
I might do like when the become an artist like this,
he ended up doing this show and you know,
selling art for thousands and thousands of dollars and just pretty much proved
that like is art,
what is art?
This guy hired two people,
other people to do all his artwork and what things and sculptures and stuff.
So it wasn't even him doing the art.
He was hiring people to do all these pieces of art and then became an artist
from that.
And it's like,
it kind of like,
that's what the point of the movie was like how crazy that journey is or what,
what is art?
You know,
there are different,
um,
opinions on the movie too.
A lot of people think the whole thing is just some banks he hoax where it really
made all that are,
he's got guy,
the camera guy was fake.
Like this is all just a big put on.
I see that.
And it could be,
I mean,
and then there's other theories where it's like,
oh,
well that guy was real.
But that was all just banks.
He's are,
I don't know,
but it's all,
it's such a great documentary.
I fucking love that.
Dot.
Good.
Yeah,
that good.
It's good.
Netflix streaming too.
So watch it on your iPhone on the shitter.
Do.
There's too many things to watch.
I just saw a Winnebago man.
Have you seen that though?
That's that guy who was the salesman.
Yeah.
Illusional Shit,
mother fucker.
I want to say that.
Well,
there's a documentary about him.
Yeah,
they went and found him.
He was pretty,
it's good.
It's,
it's a good documentary.
Yeah.
Wow.
It is.
It was pretty interesting about this guy.
Well,
no,
I mean it's funny.
They show all those old clips,
you know,
of him all the outtakes of him losing his shit and uh,
so the guy tracks him down and he's like,
this is very kind of zen dude.
And he like hangs out with them for a day and he gets home and starts getting
all these weird messages from him.
Like was that was a fucking put on like,
like the guys kind of nutty and angry.
It's just an interesting documentary.
It's just the guy.
Then the guy like,
yeah.
I don't know.
I'm confused when the bad guy.
So he calls them back and says that that was a put on.
He's like,
that wasn't really me.
I'm fucking like,
he's got problems and he's angry.
He's just like kind of,
yeah,
he's a little nutty,
but it's good.
It's actually,
yeah,
it's weird and tuck because yeah,
it's a good documentary.
Just,
it's,
there's a lot of nutty motherfuckers out there.
How about this?
Crazy guy that went nutty and Arizona.
Yeah.
I don't know much about it.
I mean,
I know what happened,
but I don't,
I haven't been reading as
they talked to his classmates,
classmates were terrified of him.
Thought he was going to shoot people.
How old was,
he was fairly young.
22.
Youtube video,
23.
[inaudible] youtube videos freaked me the fuck out.
Posted their,
there's complete disconnect in his youtube videos.
It's like he's just not making any sense whatsoever.
It's just weird,
strange just pile of words.
Hotpot Korea strange.
Very strange.
Was he just like isolated from society and you have like family or friends or
family who lived with his parents?
I believe he was just really crazy.
Obviously there's some sort of a serious mental imbalance and he um,
you know,
just went nuts and you know,
people are blaming it on Sarah Palin.
Sarah Palin had these,
um,
these,
uh,
this website,
which she had all these people that we were targeting.
Like we've got to get rid of these people in your district campaign against
them.
And she had like targets on them.
They're like little bulls eye target.
They were in a gun sites.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Gun sights.
That's the right word.
Not Targets.
That would be what you would hit.
Right?
Yeah.
Um,
but the,
the whole,
the whole thing behind it,
you know,
it's just such a fucking strange debate,
you know?
Well,
it's like,
yeah,
you really do have a certain responsibility.
You've got to recognize that the shit you're saying is flammable,
you know,
and not everybody's going to be able to handle it.
And there's a certain amount of nuts out there that if you put certain thoughts
in their head,
yeah,
they might do something really fucking crazy and they haven't done it before.
You might be the straw that breaks the camel's back.
No.
You go putting bulls eyes on people or,
or you know,
gun sights on people and there's somebody out there that might just,
that's it.
That's all they need.
And they go,
yeah,
it's not as a,
your fault that they're that fucked up.
Absolutely not.
But you've got a certain amount of fucking responsibility when you're in the
public eye in a position like that.
Crazy bitches.
You know,
someone's got to talk to her so he's going to let her know.
Like you can't encourage violence.
You can't do that because you know that you're in a bad or all your people are
savages.
Yeah.
All right.
You know your people.
Look,
I would guarantee they think that 41% of Americans believe that the earth is
less than 10,000 years old.
This is a recent Gallup poll.
41% it's,
I can't like I,
I'm so shut off.
Like,
I mean,
it's so disheartening.
It's scary,
right?
But think about those people that they can vote just like you and I can,
oh yeah.
Sarah Pailin.
If she,
if she connects,
you know,
with those people and she rides this wave of retards,
like that's,
the numbers are very high.
It gets real spooky.
I think 10 years from now,
like there's going to be a president in office that makes George Bush like look
like a fucking genius and Sarah Palin like we're not that far away.
Things are being diluted so much and people were just being dumbed down and
dumbed down like I'm dumped out.
I used to be able to tell you a hundred phone numbers.
I know my mom's phone number.
I could probably,
I probably know five phone numbers now and that's stretching it.
It's probably more like three.
Um,
I told
him,
but people but least like generations who were just being born with never having
to learn a phone number,
never having to retain information because they have Google and they have,
it's like,
yeah,
in 10 years,
if there is a 10 years,
uh,
there'll be Sarah Palin for president.
Well like,
I mean,
yeah,
there's going to be someone like her,
just some fucking Pallone
you,
it's like,
it's real obvious that we're moving in a direction where things are becoming
more complex and things are becoming more technologically advanced.
But at the same time people are getting so fucking soft.
It's almost like there's two races going on.
You know,
there's a race,
the d evolution race where we just fucking dissolve into some blob like creature
and you know,
the higher form where,
where they figure out how to,
you know,
abandoned the ego and transcend the human body and download consciousness into
computers and shit like that.
I mean that's the,
these,
there's two directions that are going at the same time.
People are devolving to the fattest laziest cons in the world,
live in America.
And then at the,
at the same time,
you know,
and,
and you know,
America's supposed to be one of the biggest first world countries,
right?
That at the top of the heap and the,
when the country's fat,
when the,
when there's money and there's technology that the,
the,
the evolution is a at a fucking staggering pace.
Well,
it's why I feel like the,
uh,
you know,
the people who are evolving,
like it's just all these people like the Sarah Pale and type people,
the people who were behind that,
that's like,
they're just,
they're cleaning,
they're clear speed bumps in their tools.
Like there,
it's easy to,
I don't know,
manipulate.
Like,
it's like there's a,
some kind of a power that doesn't want like people to be like,
it's easier to control people.
They stay stupid.
So it's like,
well,
there's never gonna be,
but they want it.
They want it to,
they want to be controlled.
I mean,
people get,
it's good,
comforting.
That's what it is.
It's fucking comforting.
You know,
when you,
when you have a certain box that you'll think in and that's it.
There's no thinking outside that box.
Jesus is right here and there's nothing above that,
right.
Bump down there,
that box that says,
I have to think anymore.
You're done.
You have much more resources at your disposal.
You don't have to think about shit.
So for a lot of people,
it's like a managing the mind tool.
You know,
for a lot of people it's like,
for them,
it's like you,
you questioning any of their shit,
it's like,
you're fucking up my mind model.
Right.
You know,
and they get angry at you.
You're making me,
Jesus are angry because like their days are just filled with sexual repression
and guilt and fucking,
you know,
it's like so crazy.
Yeah.
So that that's,
they need to channel all that towards a,
you know,
some fucking dreadlock guy
just in a cat in the hat hat fucking yeah,
you got to meet that guy.
He's got something for you.
You might,
you might want to make a separate trip making him in the parking lot.
I'm just cut the bigger bag.
I'm bummed this record store by my house is closing down and it's like,
I don't even think you can go to a record store anymore,
but it you go stores like a horse's
Bro.
Yeah.
Okay.
I took me to fucking horse.
Yeah.
As now.
I like,
I like it though too.
I like going to record stores.
I like go on a video store is still like,
I don't have Netflix.
Like Oh,
I can't do video anyway.
I don't know.
I like kind of,
part of it is just like,
I'm just going to go goof off like I did in high school.
Like go to a fucking record store,
get by and I'm just,
I don't even know what I'm here for.
Let's see.
Let's browse like,
let's like,
let's find some gem.
But like with Netflix,
like,
all right,
while I'm ordering,
you know,
a few good men and you know,
I have this queue of everything that's coming to be my entertainment for the
next and I tune same thing.
It's like,
oh well let's just walk around Amoeba,
look through the discount,
lps and God,
you'll just,
yeah,
it's like,
Oh wow,
this is fucking some shit I never would've thought of to buy me was a fantastic
place for that.
That's a great place.
You know,
I like going through a video stores too.
I like going and looking like in the horror section,
like crazy shit.
You got in here though.
It never heard of.
You tweeted about,
um,
that devil movie.
I think that at night Shambhala and I want to see that man.
I was pleasantly surprised.
A lot of people got angry with me on Twitter after I said that they get angry at
me.
They didn't like it.
Fucking movies suck.
Cock.
Now I want to see it.
We've got a violet.
I tried to read it last week,
but I was with a girl.
Fucking girls don't like scary movies.
You're dating the wrong girls.
The girls that are willing to date Brian loves scary movies.
They're all,
well then maybe that says a lot because I think I day pretty cool girls.
Yeah.
But yeah,
maybe I've never been with a girl that's in this third.
Yeah.
They never want to see scary movies.
Any girl I've ever been involved with,
I think,
hm.
I fucking loved caring movies.
Oh,
I love him too.
Fangoria I don't,
I don't like them.
You know what?
I would love every movie about an animal that eats people and they're trying to
fight it off.
You don't like that goes to the darkness.
Cleveland.
Keep making more versions of the ghost of the doctor.
So I just want lions that eat people.
Maximum overdrive was pretty sweet.
I remember that one was a big green Goblin.
Fucking cars came to life and tried to run over Emilio Estevez Yeah,
I love that.
And I remember this,
and I also liked to,
DC did the based on a Stephen King Book.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it was,
no,
it wasn't a book.
It was his first screenplay.
No,
it was the first movie he ever wrote specifically for the screen like that.
Maybe one of my second favorite horror movies was Christine's.
I just like cars and cars come in hardcore maybe shit.
I love the whole,
the change in the dude or is this real nerdy guy and then he gets this car and
then also in the car,
like fucking turns him into this bad ass.
Cool.
Motherfucker was super confident and yeah,
that was always a little creepy man.
Get a website.
It's fantastic to,
his books are great.
Like I read it a Shitload of Stephen King books in high school,
especially when he was doing coke back in those days,
the blackout days,
he really doesn't remember a lot of the books that he wrote.
Like the Tommy knockers,
one of my favorites.
He doesn't even remember writing that.
I don't think I read Tommy.
That's a man.
That dude was just,
he was just pounding here doing lines and just write in the craziest shit ever.
Was He in creep show?
Like he acted in class?
Yeah,
I got it.
Gets covered in the,
and he was dead.
His acting was so funny that faces,
he made it.
It's so weird to watch that scene.
He's crazy.
It's funny man,
because I remember when I was a kid and I would tell people that I would,
I would read Stephen King,
they almost like dismiss you as like,
you're not real serious about your writing.
Right.
You know,
why aren't you reading Dosha Yefsky or something,
you know,
why don't you read it and you know some,
some,
uh,
classic novels,
no fucking killer clown that comes out of the fucking drain and kill you the
shit.
I love those fucking books,
man.
I'm good.
They're fun.
They're exciting.
But,
but you know,
yeah.
People haven't let any mock you.
They would mock you your mind.
Yeah,
but it's like chicken.
It's fucking,
he's good.
That's why he's popular.
Like bill,
I fucking,
I like Billy Joel,
like an ironic Billy.
Joel's fucking great.
You know,
and it's like I love old Billy Joel.
We've talked about this in the podcast a bunch of times.
Really a bunch of times.
I'm glad people are talking about,
yeah,
I'm a fat tire.
Cause when I was a kid I loved Billy Joel.
That stuff that he started making like uptown girl and all this.
I was like,
well yeah,
there's some clunkers there buddy.
The uptown girl.
Yeah,
that the Shin of phase like piano man.
Dot.
It's like some of the greatest songs ever.
Yeah.
Well the stranger is like a great album,
great album.
That's almost every song on there as a fucking hit and they're all good.
52nd streets.
Good glass houses is kind of,
that's when it started to make the turn into the more kind of poppy,
I think.
Pressure.
Great Song.
Yeah.
He's a bad mother fucker.
She,
yeah,
but then you know that all their stuff,
I couldn't hang with that uptown girl type shit and I was like,
what are you doing?
Raped one of my heroes.
Some mad with the clues to do that wasn't bad.
I liked that song.
I thought it was good.
You know,
it always,
it was kind of,
he kind of went into this like Doo wop 50s kind of thing,
but there was like a thing in the 80s to where the 50s kind of were cool again.
Like was that back to the future?
I guess maybe back to the future made it like that and still rock and roll to
me,
man,
that's a good pop song.
I doesn't,
doesn't bother me.
The uptown girl,
even uptown girl shouldn't even bother me.
It's the guy wasn't love.
You've got some supermodel Posi.
Yeah,
she just let them go crazy.
If you're paying an Elle Macpherson before that was he?
Yeah,
he was just on Howard stern recently.
Bad motherfucker.
He is,
yeah.
He really fucking told in some talent almost fucking his casting couch.
It was like an ugly John Mayer,
John Mayer and Danny Devito that a kid you will ever watch.
Do you fall Danny Devito on Twitter?
I just saw what the,
I don't want to see his toe anymore.
Come on man.
Look at his tone is Danny Devito.
I know what happened.
They stuff is telling somebody.
If you want to show me your toe Bro,
I will look at it.
Respect just once in a while it was a fucking legend and just going to show you,
so you got to look at it.
I love Danny Devito.
I,
it's like kidding.
If you were in front of that,
um,
who was that fucking guy that got caught with a shotgun in the bank?
What's that fucking go live from the Larry Sanders show?
Yeah.
Rip.
Torn.
Ripped.
Yeah.
Trip torn.
Ripped.
Torn.
Yeah.
Is that his name?
I feel like that's a gay guy.
That's real.
Taylor.
The guy was crazy.
Mustache at the end of the jackass movies.
Yeah,
I saw that.
Funniest Shit last night.
And this is so old and I'm sure all I know you probably haven't seen,
but you've probably seen a million times.
Have you ever seen the old Yogi bear that the original artists of the old ren
and Stimpy,
he's uh,
was hired by cartoon network to Redo a hour of Yogi bear.
It.
They just make Yogi bear fucking crazy and booboo goes,
turns into is like raging bear instead of being a nice guy becomes like a real
bear.
John Cricket Volusia guy and he's like sick with rabies and then he grabs yogis
wife and they like start making out with like these trippy tongues is the most
fucked up Yogi bear ever and I was sitting at home stone last night and I'd,
if I was a normal Yogi bear just started watching.
I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with Yogi?
It's trippy.
You Go,
it's amazing that that Hanna Barbera let their character,
which is it used to be a kid's cartoon character into the hands of a written
stipulation.
Awesome.
Maybe.
Maybe they lost money in the financial crisis that trinal.
Yeah,
I don't know.
It's so it's called,
it's called [inaudible] has had a bar there and call them stupid theory
tightening there called booboo goes wild.
Is Hanna Barbera really an entity anymore?
Do they still make cartoons?
Cartoon Network,
right?
Hanna Barbera,
I mean did they just sell their cartoons?
When are they,
did they produce them anymore?
I think they combined with the cartoon network or something like that.
Now they are the cartoon network.
Like it's the same.
I think it's probably like Vaya con,
you know how strange is it when you watch those old cartoons?
Like when you watch with the super violent ones,
a super violent bugs bunny ones with shooting each other and Daffy duck's bill
would get shot around backwards.
Right.
Shot in the fucking things.
But yeah.
You know it's like,
but now you could,
you see it's a weird thing because you can still show those cartoons,
but you can't make a cartoon like that now.
It can make or are they just like,
I mean,
are there,
they would never hear that.
I mean if you did it,
it would be some crazy shit that you would have to have and like,
you know,
maybe south park,
they're like Ren and Stimpy on the Simpsons where they kind of do that in within
a cartoon.
[inaudible]
itchy and scratchy guys like these shows are for,
for adults,
the Flintstones and I,
that's what I grew up with.
His Flinstones.
That was a,
that was like a version of the honeymooners right there.
We're trying to do in cartoon,
Yogi and Booboo.
We're kind of like a version of the honeymooners to really,
yeah,
I know Ralph Kramden.
Yeah.
It was such a fun pairing that they tried to Redo it a bunch of different times.
SNAGGLEPUSS was a faggot.
Bryan,
Texas state's lift,
even
droopy dog and booboo had the same voice.
Yeah,
that's right.
He was an actor.
Brian wasn't necessarily gay.
Yeah.
Just cause you get off the stage to the left doesn't mean you're gay.
And then that was the of to Murgatroyd flavor slept even.
That was kind of a certain type of celebrity back then in the 60s and stuff like
you had like Liberace.
And who's The guy?
What's his fucking name?
Paul.
When Paul Lynn.
Yeah.
I love got to do,
yeah.
It's funny.
It was an unspoken thing.
Move always.
People have always loved gay people and you know,
in entertainment,
I've always been the gay guy that America loves.
You know,
there's always been a few of them,
but they never talked to a kid's cartoon.
It must've been so terrible for gay people back then to just not be able to be
out about it at all because it's not like today where you could just be walking
around with your boyfriend and Elton John Cause bring his boyfriend to some
dinner and they could hold hands.
You know Ricky Martin is on the cover of people magazine.
Him and his boyfriend,
you know they both have their babies together and they're holding hands and
shit.
Like that's all cool.
You could not do that in the 1950s man.
That was not possible.
It was an unspoken thing.
Even if you looked like the gayest mother fucker that ever walked the face of
the earth,
like Liberace.
Yeah.
You would have a billion people insisting that you are straight person.
Why aren't you married yet?
Oh Man.
Shows and stuff.
They would always ask you,
I haven't met the right woman.
Did you see the kid's cartoon?
There's a kid's cartoon called adventure time.
Have you ever seen that?
Which is a straight up lol LSD trip.
Everyone.
Every episode is just take mushrooms and that's what the cartoon is.
One of my initial question was,
why do you think it is that they were allowed to show violence like that back
then,
but now we can't because that's lacking that shit at all.
Cause back in the day it was cowboys and Indians,
you know,
it was always,
you're grown up with a gun in your hand and you're the bad guy in Greer,
the good guy,
like a war kind of thing.
I think it was more acceptable back then,
war and all that.
Because you grew up during World War One and World War Two wars going on right
now it's closer to home money.
Those two,
like it's funny to watch a guys face blow up and then it's all black and black,
you know,
fucking his hair is all.
They came back and that's fun but is coming off the top of them.
Yeah.
That's the funniest shit ever.
But then I guess people started suing people because their kids like hit their
fucking one kid,
another kid with a frying pan.
I have heard of that happening.
I have heard of a kid that hit a kid with a frying pan because he thought that
he could do that because of cartoons.
Yeah.
It's called huges watch your kids.
You Lazy cunt.
He's picking up a frying pan.
Don't want,
I'm swinging at the four year old.
I just wanted to see the head boner of the head.
Boehner that used to pop up.
It was like a longer that came out of your mind God doing,
when were the birds?
Birds would fly around that big fucking love.
Whoever.
Tree branches and girl
smoking trees.
Those fucking shows were great man.
Yeah,
I think it's just funny when you
like saw a guy like the three stooges,
you know you have a solid and curlies acting up and you just saw them in the
head.
The word question though,
how come it's okay to watch those now?
Like you could have those now in the cartoon network with all these explosions
and all this shit is going on,
but you could not make a new cartoon like that for kids.
I don't know man.
Cause like,
I'm like I was saying,
I've been watching these cartoons lately.
They're fucking crazy now.
You know,
there's literally,
it's a lot.
I mean,
GI joes a lot different than it was back
in saying,
don't ask,
don't tell shit going on
chest hair.
Duke has chest now digs,
Duke has chest hair and do chest hair.
Now you're,
you're like the Paul into this show.
He is.
He's straight as fuck too.
He's fine.
You can see it online.
I saw a clip of him.
Um,
he used to be on Hollywood squares all the time.
Yeah.
And the,
the question the guy asked me,
he goes,
so Paul a,
when a,
uh,
when a man falls off of a boat,
they say man overboard.
What do they say when a woman falls off a boat and he goes full speed ahead.
Full speed ahead.
So funny too.
I want to listen to Poland has a Halloween special that's supposed to be insane.
It's hard to get a copy of it,
but it was like 1976 maybe you did this Halloween special for cvs.
It's supposed to be insane.
Really?
Yeah.
That I knew from Boston who was one of those gay guys and never really would say
he was a gay guy on stage who talked about his girlfriend on stage,
but he was really gay guy.
Very fascinating character.
But he uh,
he said first time I ever saw with John,
I was like,
oh,
when's it going to heal?
I can't actually said that.
And when's it going to heal?
Yeah.
Don't trust anything that bleeds.
Was she on her period?
Because then that could,
I don't know.
Yeah,
no,
I know.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah,
fine.
It's a weird,
it's a weird hole.
Yeah.
I was out with this girl the other day that had,
she doesn't like wearing underwear and she has a hole in her pants,
right with her pussy is,
and you don't notice it until like you,
she sits down and she doesn't cross her legs and uh,
see some pubes are just right there and it's ridiculous.
Her Pussy,
he's got like pollutants.
Yeah.
I go running up and printing cloth and I go,
why?
Why do you have that excuse?
I just like these jeans and it's kind of cool.
You get to Eric [inaudible] against the fucking pussy out there rubbing against
the park bench.
Shit.
Plastic seat at Mcdonald's.
It's like homeless dude.
Just fart all Mrs. Rodriguez.
It appears you have pigeon shit inside your vagina.
Any idea how this happened?
The black hole.
It's trying to suck dicks in there and anything else that's close.
He'll take their cat litter.
That prison shit.
It's like a shop vac.
Yeah,
just shot back for,
that's your vagina's just sucking in pigeon shit and Piss and shit.
ACORNS got acorns.
Pussy,
Vaginas,
flyers.
The heard she's cute.
Bird stuck up their flyers that were stuck under people's names.
Shields and they,
I'm on the fucking ground.
It's all stuck.
Postcard size.
You should go to jail if you make flyers you fuckhead.
Yeah.
You know I was thinking about making a website cause I just got another one on
on my street too.
And it's some for some computer thing,
but I want to make a website of like don't support these companies like every
race.
That fucking annoying to me man.
Because now I have to take,
I don't want to litter because now it's my responsibility to put it on my car.
Yeah,
you fucking shit head.
I'm not getting you.
You're not cleaning my carpet.
No.
Clean my fucking carpet.
No,
I'll call everyone else before the fucking nuisance.
Who put a thing under my windshield wiper.
Now I got to deal with,
I got to throw your trash to get our business out there.
Isn't it funny you don't ever get attacked by one?
You get attacked by six like you know,
usually it's not just one little flyer.
If you get one little fly,
you get them on your side windows.
Also Different Co,
what's the name?
You know what?
It might be the same company.
I'm wondering how many people like hire a service to go spam.
I mean there must be some sort of service that the flyers and it must be right?
Yeah,
it's like some kind of street team.
Some guys on roller blades and a fucking mail sack shoulder bag.
Make a deal with a bunch of different businesses and say,
hey,
we'll print up little cards for you.
I'll,
we'll go out on my street team.
Yeah.
Some dude's we pay four bucks an hour.
There was a street team that was like part of the,
when I had a,
a CD at Warner brothers,
it was my first CD and they,
there was like a,
a marketing budget and part of the marketing budget was a street team or going
out and putting fucking,
they're gonna vandalize,
right?
Yeah.
Put on the,
put the stickers on the handout.
People,
you know,
hand out posters and shouldn't put them on walls and handout CD packets.
Like your spam little cards down at the coffee shop postcards or your picture on
them.
Is that,
is that the one with the,
uh,
where the two guys are working out and start but fucking you guys,
Bryan County.
Yeah.
It's me and my friend Bryan cone.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
Um,
they play that on Sirius a lot actually.
Yeah.
Howard still plays that are oh yeah,
that's right.
It was Howard.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Our,
uh,
it is,
that was,
uh,
the one thing that I would have happened was that we made a CD or I made a c d
and I wanted to make a sketch that it was so fucked up.
You can only hear,
it
wouldn't be funny to see why she's guys really fucked each other.
No,
but there's something funny about it was so ridiculous because there's always
guys like if you're around any people that are like real body builder type
people,
once they start complimenting each other on different portions of their body,
like you crossed this weird line,
like you might as well just start kissing each other.
Rise section it couple of years.
It's weird,
man.
They start talking about your adults man.
The way they're coming in,
they just fucking delta.
Amazing.
Just a
align pro from the pack to the Delt.
That's,
that's beautiful symmetry right there.
You think so?
I've never had that talk in my life.
Oh Man.
It's a weird,
the bodybuilder talk is weird talk man.
When did you sit next to a dude and all of a sudden you realize he shaves his
legs and you go,
Oh,
snap side.
Yeah,
it's going on up here.
Yeah.
I'm so distant from that.
I don't know.
It's a weird thing man.
I'm trying to develop my calves,
man.
I'm,
I want avoid getting the implant.
But yeah,
just trying to,
you know,
try to bulk them up a man.
It's hard.
I'm super set in of doing a lot.
We think about my calves,
so there's like a dude who's on his knees.
[inaudible]
it's,
you know,
it's not as bad as you think,
man.
It looks small,
Bro.
I'm telling you,
they're not that bad bro.
You know,
Frank Zane at very small calves
just want to suck her cock.
That's what they really want to do.
They want to just dive on in there.
Yeah.
Or they just,
yeah.
We had those guys in high school that were really concerned about their bodies
and working out.
So to the months that there was this one guy that had those Popeye calves where
it was just like this huge bubble.
And there's like a 16 year old kid.
You'd just be like,
I don't even wear pants up,
man.
What's wrong with this guy?
Some people just have cats like that.
My Dad,
my dad has these giant calves and he doesn't work out at all.
It doesn't do shit.
He's fucking big.
Like they're twice as big as one.
It's just like his,
his natural,
crazy calves.
It's a dead kind of has big calves like that soft.
Some people just have one weird soft.
Yeah.
My Dad a soft milky.
Like
some people just have frequent leg muscles.
Man.
They're like probably got some lot of neanderthal in them,
you know?
Yeah.
So Paul had some freak leg muscles.
Yeah,
that's what I'd think.
All right.
Yeah.
This podcast is also sponsored by marijuana.
[inaudible].
The tangents were going off calf muscles,
fucking neanderthals and shit.
Oh yeah.
But your sketch,
that's how we started on that.
What did we start off with?
The your CD,
the thing where you Brian Count fucking banging each other.
Yeah.
There's something gained about being really into your body,
but the reason why it starts those,
because chicks like it.
That's what happens.
Boys value the boys find out that it makes other men jealous when they have
muscles and the girls like it,
so then they get obsessed with their body,
but then somewhere along the line or spending too much time with other dudes,
you know,
spotting them while they're squatting,
yelling in your ear and just grunting and there's just a pleasure.
All the pleasure chemicals are connected to this one.
Then you find like when you're getting laid,
you're checking yourself out more in the mirror.
When you check your bag in,
you know that's got happen,
right?
Well that's like never done.
You got to check out some of you like you want to check out looking at my penis
going in there.
Right there.
Hmm.
I want the lights out.
I don't want to see anything.
That's a creepy one.
They went the lights out.
Yeah.
I've only had a couple of girls ever in my whole life,
so they want the lights totally out.
I'm like,
what?
We can't even look at each other.
Yeah.
That's of the phone.
Now I've got to get an infrared camera for this room.
That was something that was some Boston Catholic guilt shit stuck in some poor
chicks head or the Catholic yet.
Kind of like the lights and little logo.
I don't like it.
Right.
You don't like,
we don't like when it's bright and I like it like a,
like maybe a TV.
A fluorescent lamp.
Well,
as long as you can clearly make out body shapes and shit.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Clearly.
Look at each other.
Why don't we go?
Why are we all looking at,
she was nothing wrong with banging in the daylight either,
Huh?
Yeah.
No,
I like the morning sex to the best sex.
Oh,
the Catholic guilt.
That's what I were you brought up Catholic?
Yeah,
me too.
For a little bit,
but not from my all.
First grade was the last,
the last of it I went to a Catholic school.
It was so horrible that,
um,
my parents were getting divorced at the same time.
They sent me to this Catholic school and I went from nothing.
I didn't go to kindergarten anywhere.
I just went right to first grade,
first grade Catholic school,
just fucking crazy nun.
She was so evil.
Her crazy,
so evil and so vindictive and mean and you know,
and just intimidating to children.
Yeah.
That any ideas that I had about religion just stopped dead right dead straight
there.
I was like,
there is no way this bitch is talking for God.
I'm like,
this is all craziness,
but these are all crazy people.
When you're around them,
you feel terrible.
You got to get the fuck away from them.
And I,
you can see the hypocrisy and see the anger and see the hear the shit that they
were talking about when they were,
you know,
when the priest was on stage talking.
And the difference between that and the way they were acting like this is like,
this is insanity.
Like this is a tech torture colony.
You're just fucking kid's heads up.
It is.
Yeah,
it does.
It fucks you up.
I did it for eight years,
first through eighth grade and when I was in second grade,
this is one of the most fucked up things.
I was in second grade and I was in the,
um,
they do like that passion play that it's like this thing they do around Easter
where like a bunch of kids you put on a little play or whatever.
And uh,
so I was like in whatever this chorus thing,
and one of my friends,
Jimmy was an apostle and we're at rehearsal in church and uh,
they're playing some music and there's some like acoustic guitar in the,
in the,
in the song.
So I tried to get Jimmy's attention.
I get his attention and go like,
Eh,
like make believe I'm seven,
you know,
and uh,
and then sister Diane,
this woman starts like stops.
Everything starts screaming at me.
This is God's house.
You don't behave like that in God's house.
Wa like,
yells at me,
embarrasses the shit,
makes me feel like shit.
I go home and she's doing it right when my mom's coming to pick me up too,
which is also like,
oh great.
My mom.
See me getting screened at,
cause I got in trouble a lot,
but either way.
So I go home next day I'm back in school and somebody comes to class or like
sister Diane wants to or she comes and she's like,
oh sister Diane wants to see you in the hallway.
And I walk out of the class seven years old.
And I even remember too,
when I'm walking out,
I did look a funny dance to try to make one of my friends laugh or yeah,
make one of my friends,
as soon as I get out in the hallway,
she grabs me by my tie and like picked me up and she's like,
if you,
you don't do that in God's house.
This is a day later.
She's like screaming at me about what I did in church,
the knife,
a little air guitar.
I just,
yeah.
And I like just burst into tears.
Like,
I mean I'm seven,
somebody just,
I forgot about the whole fucking incident.
It's the next day.
And she grabs me and gets in my face and,
and yeah,
it makes me cry and I have to go back into my class.
I'll fucking,
everybody could tell her crying.
That's crazy.
I'm glad I didn't grow for a bunch of fucking dykes who are not die.
I'm not,
whatever lesbians.
Third,
a lot of lesbians are nice.
They're issue is that the,
first of all,
they've committed to something completely and totally irrational.
And by the time you become a certain age,
you start to realize that and you have to shut off parts of your brain in order
to live this crazy,
you know,
semi monastic lifestyle.
Well,
they're living a lie.
Like they really want to look each other's pussies,
but they're like,
well,
we're going to go to health.
We do that.
So we need to again,
like channel this fucking energy.
Oh,
that kid just fucking spit on the ground.
Let's go.
Like beat the shit out of him with a ruler and make them say prayers and Neil on
chalk and all kinds of weird shit they made up.
Yeah.
And,
you know,
and there's a lot of people that there's defendant and they say,
Hey,
you know,
my church was not like that and we were doing okay.
I believe you.
And I'm not saying that it's all like that,
but God damn a lot of look across the board,
the weird,
some people went through a good Catholic program and it was okay,
but they maybe even,
they're willing to tolerate a lot of shit that you and I wouldn't,
there's a certain amount of rules that you just say,
well that's the way the rules are.
And for a lot of people they're like,
hey,
why fight the rules?
But for most comics,
most people who have the mind of a comment,
you know,
it's like this real stupid,
what does this rule?
Why is this here?
Yeah,
well was six school squashes all that shit?
Well and they don't tolerate silling like,
you know,
like,
cause I wasn't a fucking like given teachers,
I wasn't like one of those kids like fuck you.
Right.
I just was like,
yeah,
just trying to make my friends laugh and like I didn't give a fuck about what
they were talking about.
I just wanted to make my friend John laughed with this fucking picture I drew or
face I'm making or a penis.
It produces people draw a lot of decks always guilty and joyless.
That sort of predicts producers or are there a lot of guys like us who fucking,
I mean I've been thinking about actually reading that war of art book too.
Not that they really talk about it in there,
but I'm starting to recognize like I like I think I am kind of fucked up.
Like it seems cliche like to be fucked up from this Catholic shit that was
crammed down your throat when you're a kid.
But it's like yeah I think I do.
I am kind of fucked up from that.
Like there are certain kinds of like insecurities and like,
cause I got in trouble for fucking goofing off all the time and now my whole
life is goofing off your professionally.
Then I feel guilty about it or like do you really?
Yeah.
Like,
I feel.
Yeah.
How do you feel guilty?
Do you feel guilty?
Like,
Hey,
this isn't like a legitimate way to make a living.
You should be do somebody like what do you feel guilty about?
Well,
I'll,
um,
sometimes,
well this is kind of a whole different can of worms,
but I do think that this,
it's like it's really self absorbed,
self serving selfish kind of like 90% of my brain powers thinking about me and
what I'm doing,
you know?
And so I do think it's kind of an empty existence sometimes.
It's like,
well,
you know,
maybe you should just be helping people,
like actually really doing something instead of fucking worrying about,
you know,
taping the fucking set on a TV show,
like four minutes of jokes.
Um,
but also like I,
yeah,
I just like,
I know there's like kind of a weird kind of fear of success I think I have from
it too,
where it's like,
cause I'm always like saying,
well I'm not good enough.
Right?
Because everybody was telling me I'm a fucking idiot when I'm a kid.
And then the knock it the fuck off and now it's like,
oh,
like there's weird kind of,
it's a mixed bag.
Like,
yeah,
you feel like you're fighting against it all the time.
Like you're swimming up river
or I'm playing chicken with something,
you know,
where it's like,
Oh,
here's where I want to be.
Or here,
you know,
like yeah,
playing chicken with success or whatever where it's just like,
oh right when I'm getting to it,
I'm gonna fucking flinch because I don't have the fucking balls or the,
you know,
confidence or,
shit that was kind of tried to be shaken out of me when I was a kid.
Yeah.
I think that's a real valid point,
man.
I think,
you know,
especially seeing little children growing up now,
being around my daughters and and seeing how they evolve,
like as little human beings and how you're programming your input shapes out
their confidence shapes the way they do things.
Like I've seen my little daughter change from being scared to be around kids to
being like really social.
They're like a short period of time.
Like,
like fearless,
like dives into groups of kids and starts playing and it's really like us slow
metamorphosis of just just communicating with her and showing her,
you know,
how to,
how to be around people and what's fun and you know,
just like getting to Kinda like give them a framework of how to think about
things.
But the framework that you get from the Catholic school is so jacked.
It's so your bad guilt,
you're terrible person.
You're in near legitimate person,
you're going to Shane,
your parents,
you're shaming God.
It's all this like Fox,
you suck.
It's all,
it's,
it's just this terrible fucking over overpowering suppression feeling,
you know?
That's crazy.
Cause my,
my,
my whole religion growing up was completely a hundred percent different than
that.
Kind of says you just go Sunday and what,
what kind of his teaching Christian Lutheran.
Lutheran.
But it was more like mellow.
It was like,
so here's what we believe and let's just talk about it.
Cool.
You didn't go to the like a Lutheran school or no,
no.
I just went to,
I folks
weren't like crazy religious.
Like I had to go to church on Sundays up until,
you know,
I was 14.
Oh.
Like when they were like,
I'm not fucking arguing with you anymore or do whatever you want.
But uh,
my folks weren't like super religious.
This is all the school shit.
Like these nuns and priests and,
yeah.
Well it's,
I mean,
yeah,
the,
nobody's cracking any fucking case saying the Catholic
fucking religions fucked up.
I mean,
yeah.
Well the,
you know,
it's just interesting that I've talked to so many different people that have
gone through some sort of a troubling religious background.
Ari Shaffir with Judaism.
Yeah.
Like a hurry was like a serious practitioner.
We'd read the Talmud like 12 hours a day and you know,
he was living in Israel.
I mean,
like you went deep with it.
[inaudible] you got to call her on the line.
It's not going to work in here anyway.
There's no signal in here.
It will sound terrible.
It's Doug Stanhope is you want to try?
I'm getting,
oh wait,
my bars just went away.
Yeah,
there's not much signal up yet.
We could fucking stripper ass phone.
Uh,
try to get a call up here with t mobile son.
Hey Douglas.
Me Boy.
Okay.
It's Joe Rogan.
We're doing our podcast right now.
Oh,
what are you doing rather than what's going on?
No,
this is me.
Okay.
He can,
Oh yeah,
I guess you get it.
Yeah.
That's what now everybody knows they're gonna rip me off.
People are going to get your phone number,
another call with a fake accent.
I can post it online every day.
Do you,
do you really give out your phone number,
man?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I saw the,
uh,
those guys who interviewed you on the Internet.
They just,
some dude just showed up at your house and you gave him the directions to your
house.
Wow.
And you didn't know nothing about this dude?
No.
I just kept ignoring it until he said
I shouldn't be there sometime in the morning.
I hope to run into you,
but to keep great break.
Douglas,
you're an original.
My friend,
Huh?
Well,
it is what it is that a lot,
a long time listener.
First Time.
What's the phrase that pays?
Uh,
Joe Rogan in the house?
What
is this?
Ralphie May.
Are we still on with Doug Stanhope?
Who is this?
Okay.
Yeah.
You think he's gonna not gonna make it?
I think he makes it through sheer force of will and weed.
He's going to come up with 20 celebrities,
fluid,
black humor,
Tom Sizemore and the last minute.
Oh,
nice.
That's good one.
That's a good,
that's a good trade.
Lewis Black is fine,
but it is a good man are rooting for him.
We want you to read them.
All of them.
Oh,
Michael Douglas is out of the,
out of the woods.
It's very strange.
Celebrity Rehab coming back off clean and sober to talk to the flunkies.
Whoa.
You know your fuck with Tom.
Size wars giving you advice and that turned your life around.
Did you watch the celebrity rehab?
I know you have.
You've tweeted about doctor drew.
Have you been watching this year with the check that fuck tiger woods.
He's my favorite.
She's,
it's not even close.
It's like people's moms and shit.
It's like some cigarettes mom and some dudes are rich.
His dad's rich,
so he's always designated fucking famous scot back.
You'll is nice.
It's fucking fascinating.
And then the girl who fuck tiger woods who was just addicted to love.
It's fucking fantastic.
Are you in La again?
Are you,
are you back yet?
Okay.
All right brother.
Well we'll uh,
we'll talk soon.
I'll see this week man.
For sure
tomorrow.
Alright brother later talk to you later
is gentleman.
That was powerful.
Doug Stanhope live via speaker phone.
It's the first time they've ever attempted this on the podcast.
We've never done a speaker phone to a microphone.
Cell phone,
impromptu conversation.
That was pretty good for,
yeah,
I mean we're talking about him earlier and stuck standing health.
How could you ever get anything better than that?
You're always getting,
he's always gonna nail it.
Yeah,
he's always good.
It's consistent.
Except one time when I called in to a Seattle station instead of him over,
he was out of the country and Oh yeah,
you were doing that for awhile.
That was only did it once or twice.
Maybe.
Yeah,
we had heard about that.
That you had done some interviews for pretending to be him.
Yeah,
cause he was,
I forget.
Oh he was out.
I think him and like Andrist and Shaw craft.
They was like going to be out in the woods or something and there was no
reception.
Oh yeah.
That thing they used to do that.
There wasn't the desert party.
It was some other thing.
I forget what the fuck,
but either way,
Hennigan,
his manager called,
Oh,
do you want it to anyone you want to do a phone in for dog?
Andrew's Irish,
he's Scottish.
She's Scottish.
Jimmy never met Brian.
I don't mind that.
I must have,
did you ever see the video?
I put up a Doug,
uh,
where he couldn't make it to an interview at a car show.
So I put up,
hit some local comic in San Francisco and he played the role of Doug Lee.
He had sunglasses on and a hat.
And it was so funny because the guy was just saying the most ridiculous thing.
So I'll just such a fun guy to know because he's like,
he's really doing everything that I,
you know,
he's supposed to be doing.
You know,
like guy gets a vasectomy,
you know,
he lives in
a fucking crazy yellow house in the middle of nowhere.
He goes on the road,
he doesn't go to the comedy clubs and steady books,
things on his own.
Very rarely going to comedy clubs,
books,
things on his own and rock clubs develops his own following on the Internet
becomes subtle.
Totally self sufficient.
Yeah.
He's really doing it,
you know,
he's doing it the perfect way.
I mean,
that's really Doug,
you know,
there's no expectation.
You know who he is.
He's a genuine dude.
Have you been to his place?
No.
We're going to go for the super bowl.
He's having a party.
I going to work super bowl weekend.
It's a UFC.
That's right.
Yeah.
We bet on that too.
I want,
I can fly in on Sunday.
They,
I could fly from the UFC to you guys at my ex.
Be Fun.
That would be fun.
Yeah.
Where's,
how far away is it from an airport?
Tucson airport I think is an hour,
hour and a half,
two sides of crazy ass play.
So that's where that kid came from.
That's where the shooter,
that's a wild west baby.
There's a,
there's a hotel there called the hotel congress in Tucson and they have a very
stuck and I performed there.
They have a,
um,
it's a cool performance space,
but it's like this old timey hotel,
like a deal injures somebody got captured.
There are stuff that are slipped.
I don't know.
There was two song of view we'd do shows.
This is at the,
at that place.
I have this form there twice with Doug.
Oh,
so no shows in Tucson.
That's cool.
Wow.
Does living in Arizona,
you have like more of an Arizona following now?
Does he have a lot of people that way?
It's a weird little town he lives in now.
It doesn't perform in his town.
Right.
He's done a show I think.
Really?
Yeah,
like lawn or to suck him.
Rick Shapiro.
Well,
I mean fuck,
we just had them on the phone.
It gets all these stories better than me.
He told me,
I think,
I think we was saying once about how it would be kind of weird if,
you know,
they all saw,
I was like,
abortion joke and then he has to run into at the supermarket,
you know,
he has these,
there's um,
some of his neighbor's neighbor,
Dave and Evelyn are just like two regular Evelyn works at the Safeway.
Dave works for Frito lay.
They're just like super nice people,
but they're like regular.
It was regular as can be.
And uh,
and they're like,
yeah,
Doug's best friends.
But they,
it's like,
I don't think they've seen too much of what he'd like.
They know that he's like a comedian and I think he said he showed Dave some
stuff and he's like,
oh yeah,
that's,
you know,
but they're calling them neighbor Dave neighbor Dave.
Yeah.
If you read dozens,
a,
I think neighbor Dave was just in the hospital for something and Doug was doing
one of those things where he's getting people to send them weird stuff.
Doug does not get the credit enough credit.
It just doesn't,
it doesn't for just genuine human beings respected across the bull.
Yeah,
no,
I agree with that.
That's not what I mean.
I mean,
he should be,
he should be stadium enormous.
Yeah.
He should be like one of the biggest guys ever.
I mean,
yeah,
it's,
there's,
there's like,
I don't know what it is.
It's like for me,
if you wanted to construct,
if you wanted to construct the comedian that I could go to see as a lifelong
standup comedian.
Yeah.
You know,
Turkestan a perfect guy.
Yeah.
No,
I'm going to hear some crazy take on something that I either a agree with or I
could see his point and it's,
he takes me into a place I didn't see common.
It's hilarious and it's all well thought out and it's all constantly evolving
and it's all always interesting.
It's always real and it's like,
God damn that is stand up fucking comedy like that.
That's the real shit right there.
Yeah.
There's not many people like him,
like seeing a Doug Stan hope showed that I can think of.
There's so many countries,
a few comics man,
where I'm always like,
Whoa,
how come the whole world doesn't know about Nick Depaulo?
Well you ever seen Nick Depaulo kill?
I've never seen,
I've never seen nick live outside of a like Montreal short.
Let me tell you something.
When I was coming up,
when I was in like 1988 when I was doing open mic nights,
Nick Depaulo was a couple of years ahead of me and he was just a fucking killer.
Even then,
like he always had like sick timing and great writing and uh,
I went to see him,
uh,
Shit.
It was a couple of years ago.
He was doing one of the late night shows.
What are you doing there in Brendan Walsh?
Can Lean back that I was trying to get them to stick up.
Okay.
We'll take this is panicking yet.
Anyway,
I hadn't seen him and fucking forever and I almost forgot how funny he was.
He just destroyed,
destroyed and everything's got that fucking Boston thing going on.
You know,
everything's got that fucking Boston accent that hadn't,
this is talking about,
uh,
people in,
in Katrina not getting rescued.
He goes,
uh,
maybe I know where to find it.
If you could fucking spell.
He goes,
it doesn't say on the roof Hep,
you want some happen,
zip your mouth and add water.
It's like,
I'm totally paraphrasing and nick,
have you hear that?
I apologize for butchering your joke.
I'm sure I did,
but I was just like,
this motherfucker's so funny.
He's just like so that that hard Boston style.
Funny to just Pam,
Pam.
Yeah.
A lot of good guys came out of that.
I'm hoping that with the,
the new media,
with,
you know,
the Internet's and podcasts and shit like that.
I'm hoping that there's going to be some people that would get reintroduced to a
whole new group of humans.
But there's a lot of people like that,
like,
you know,
like there's a lot of comics that for whatever reason they just,
people lost touch with them.
They disconnected with them because they didn't get on Twitter and they haven't
done anything on comedy central and a long time and people just sort of forget.
It's still good.
Still go to fall between the cracks or it's,
some kids get tired of it too.
You know?
Some dudes gives just get tired of performing good tired of writing and then
they fade off.
That's,
that's a possibility too.
Yeah.
And a lot goes.
I mean,
you know,
if you get a reputation as being a fucking pain in the ass or head or,
or a crazy person,
like,
yeah,
then nobody's gonna,
you know,
they're like,
Eh,
it's easier to give this guy a show who doesn't drink and shows up on time.
Who cares if he humps a stool for a fucking hour?
I'm not talking about anybody in particular.
I'm just saying that like,
I know what you mean there.
Some really,
I mean like rouse Shawn Ross,
one of the funniest dudes on the planet.
Like,
what are you gonna do with them though?
You know,
like
I,
nobody wants to babysit.
I'm on the road,
right?
Yeah.
He's,
he's trying that.
He's totally clean this shit up.
I mean,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
that sounds like Scott,
he's just got so many health problems too.
That's the problem.
But he would get pretty like,
you know,
a lot of clubs that that he would work at that I'd be afterwards you're like,
oh,
what did you hear about what Ross did?
Who was here and he could be a handful when he's drinking.
I guess there's always a dude,
this is always a Pablo Francisco story.
There's always
crazy.
I don't know him the best.
I will say nothing.
Everybody has an insane story about him.
Like everybody,
anybody who's met him for two seconds,
fucking,
he's got such good energy.
That guy,
he's always got this friendly,
happy energy.
You know?
I like it.
I remember at the other day when we were at the Improv where you there where he,
I was talking to him before a show or something and he goes outside.
He's like,
you do a lot of videos and these are real conversation.
It was like,
I have a conversation with Pablo and you won't,
you won't even know if you're really talking to,
right.
Yeah.
It's like talking to robocop
Tuesday night.
That's the way he talks.
Well,
he'll just sometimes go into character and just start.
Oh,
he's just having fun and it's really funny.
There's certain
mean,
you know,
it's so funny man.
Just certain comics just have good energy.
You can just be around them.
There's other guys that even if I funny,
even if they're funny,
just like let me just keep the fuck away from you until you go on stage.
Then I'll watch it in the back and then I'll get
the fuck away from you when you get off stage.
I envy those guys with that positive like where everybody in the room's 20%
happier that like that dude showed up cause I can be moody and it's like,
well you know what I mean?
Like it's like,
oh why aren't I always just like,
Hey let's have fun and laugh all the time.
But sometimes I'm like,
man,
if you could do it all over.
Yeah.
Again you would.
If you were an old man on your death bed and someone said to you,
listen,
I can make you 20 again.
You can be living the party all over.
You'd be pro comedian,
stand standup comic out there running around telling jokes,
having a good fucking time,
making people laugh right now.
What do you think you would be ecstatic ripped for?
Or You'd be like,
fuck man,
I'm ready to go meet God.
Yeah,
I'm turn to the next dimension.
You're gonna make me live this stupid material life over again.
They get inside of Malcovich so he could see it two ways.
But I think if you did want to go back,
I mean you would really appreciate the fuck out.
Yeah,
well I think about that all the time that there is going to be a last fucking
day and like,
you know,
it's like,
Whoa,
you're not really fucking going to nuts.
It's,
it's,
you know what,
we're in a weird
Tom because right now life,
you know,
the expectancy is getting longer and longer because there's supplements and
exercise and taking care of your body and you know,
medical treatments and making sure that people are,
you know,
that you get checkups on a regular basis so they catch anything that's fucked
up.
You know?
And when,
when when people start to live longer and longer and longer right there and then
they start inventing new things.
When they start getting into like gene technology and getting into,
you know,
Myostatin inhibitors for your body and you know,
different forms of,
you know,
nanobots to eradicate and it's going to be
some crazy shit in our lifetimes.
They could easily extend the,
you know,
the average lifespan to like,
maybe even like 150 years.
The average wealthy guy or she imagined trying to talk to some 20 year old
bitch.
When you're 150 you're 115 you still look like you're 30 like you're 150 years
old.
But for whatever reason,
like thank you.
Like keep your body like Stallone style fully prepared and then you're like 150
and to try and talk to some chicks,
she's like 20 I've noticed lately as 130 when you were born,
could you imagine that conversation?
She 150 year old dude,
you know,
you know the best.
Oh,
I can't,
I mean I can't even hang out with 24 years.
The worst is when friends have girlfriends and like I have some friends that are
like in their late thirties and they'll have a girlfriend that's in their young
20 [inaudible] and then all of a sudden you're,
you're all hanging out together and you know,
and like the conversation takes us left,
turns into walls and it just spins out.
It's like,
why are you letting her hold the steering wheel?
Man,
this is,
you know,
we were having a great conversation and all of a sudden what?
Bang or into the rocks just cause you're fucking plow and are like I don't come
into the bedroom and tried to fucking hang out.
You're,
I don't know,
I've tried to think of a good analogy but it's like the only reason she's here
is because you like fucking,
you know,
bouncing around your fucking Dick Talk.
Well I understand,
you know,
giving it a try.
You know what,
let's to hang out when you're going to be with are cool as long as they're not
obnoxious
about dating a girl really young is like when,
when you date like a 22 year old,
they haven't seen a lot of the movies that you know are guaranteed.
Awesome.
So if you want to have a good night,
my canvas just,
you know,
has some Hawaiian,
has some steaks and then we're going to watch uh,
you know,
name,
movie here,
you know,
like just like 80 or something,
she would be like having a great night.
So it's so cool.
Cut Back.
Cause I,
I love that.
Where did she,
like I was robbing the cradle bitch and try to come up with reasons why they
could not.
It was a girl who didn't know who gene Hackman was recently.
Whoa.
Really?
And I was like,
yeah,
I mean yeah,
she didn't know who gene Hackman was,
but I guess it's understandable because it's like,
oh yeah,
you,
you were born in like 1990.
My friend that I brought last night didn't know who Dan Akroyd was last night
and I was trying to show her pictures a day and acronym like you've seen
Ghostbusters,
right?
And she's like,
no,
what's Ghostbusters?
It's such a weird thing for guys.
If a guy's a single guy and he's like real shit.
If a guy who's like in his late thirties I right and you're,
you're,
you're looking for a check.
If you,
you can go one or two ways,
you can either go really young where you got to kind of almost babysit him.
Well,
you've got to kind of look,
reteach him life and you know,
hang,
I mean,
how many times wait for that in the break up with you in five years or yeah.
That,
that could be it.
Or you know,
or you can go your age,
right?
And when you go your age,
what a fucking risk that is.
Yeah.
You know what's cool about the young girls to 36 year old check.
There's some bitterness involved in that package.
Most of the time someone's angry at somebody and someone left somewhere and some
would promise me something.
And there was some money that was supposed to go up there and we were going to
buy a house together and my car still under his name and Eh,
yeah.
Desperately want to get their claws in someone because they know like this,
you know,
I'm
sure he's right around the car
corner and they've been hurt before,
so they're,
they're defensive,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
some of them pulled together and you know,
they'd take yoga classes and they get their shit together and they'd go to
crossfit and all of a sudden they're reading books and taking healthy.
There's this 36 year olds that are happy to be saying,
I'm not saying they're all tiny things.
All of them were,
I mean,
we're,
we're doing is,
you know,
I'm not saying if it's you out there and you fit this profile,
don't get upset.
Yeah.
Well I think that it is,
it's ty,
I really sympathize with women.
Like they do have a lot of fucking,
a lot more problems than we do and they can get,
it's unfortunate.
Well,
yeah,
they can get pregnant and you're stuck with some like some guy who just banged
you on night,
then you have it.
He's connected to him forever and then you need him financially guides.
I don't even want to talk about it cause it makes me sad.
It,
it's just bums me out that like,
ah,
fuck that shit.
Just,
it's ridiculous that it's still okay
works that way.
It should be so clear whether or not we,
we have babies or not as good as my kid screaming ground quiet please.
Anyway.
Um,
it should be so clear.
It shouldn't be just some random loads sneaks through and,
and in pregnancy you,
it should be like so super duper clear.
There should be like,
it should be difficult.
We should make it more difficult to have babies.
It's easy to put plan B in a person's breakfast though,
but killing them Brian,
you've disrupted the cycle.
But to kill,
even if it's two sounds,
just cook them breakfast and you know,
no life.
But to finish that thought though,
it's like I can understand girls wanting like getting desperate around like
majorities because it sucks at,
it sounds shitty to say,
but they're just,
they fall off the sexual radar and like dude's fucking,
she's don't,
for whatever reason,
like they just can keep,
you know,
they can leave their 55 year old wife for 32 year old chick and
as long as the man,
but then only represents a position of power where the woman feels attracted to
him cause he can provide,
it's almost always that 55 year old broke dudes aren't worth shit.
But a 55 year old guy with a Ferrari,
you can get some 20 year old posts.
Just a decent job.
You know,
like a guy who makes 150 grand a year or something,
you know,
or yeah.
Yeah.
It's possible.
If he's a good guy,
you know,
find a solid check that's in her thirties and it's usually doesn't work the
other way around,
but the wife is kind of screwed,
you know,
it's harder for,
there was a video that was online that I was talking about and it's,
it was on Twitter and I put it up there and it's really horrendous to watch.
It's really hard to watch.
It's this guy getting conned by these Nigerian scammers.
You got conned out of $300,000 he's not a rich guy.
It was his,
his pension,
everything you ever saved his entire life.
And he got conned into thinking that this porn star,
they put pictures of this porn star on,
you know,
send him all these emails and photos of her that this was her,
that he was communicating with her.
And then she needed money.
And at one point in time he was giving her $1,600 a day,
was going to these Nigerian scammers.
He flew to London 14 times on 14 separate occasions to meet her,
but never got in contact with her.
Like he would literally fly all the way to London and go,
what the,
where is she,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
[inaudible]
14 times,
14 times.
He kept doing it,
kept doing it.
He was so convinced that this girl was real.
Like somehow or another the,
they had him so convinced and they had like the,
the,
the email logs,
you know,
they're the show and how they went back and forth and they just scan this
motherfucker and they just robbed.
What point is,
I don't know what I was saying on Twitter.
I was like,
this is just like a limping Willdabeast getting eaten alive by Hyenas.
This is what it is.
This is some weak minded,
crazy person,
you know,
who's gotten old and gotten a bit soft,
a little senile.
I mean it happens.
Old People lose their grip on reality.
This guy was like deep in his sixties it looked like and then then all of a
sudden they just locked a hold of his brain and rekindle that spark of romance.
Just the the thought that may be,
it could be real.
And this is 23 year old fucking super hot porn.
Pornstar really was in love with this old dope because he was senator $1,600 a
day.
I mean this guy was like,
it happens.
It happens.
You never know man.
I'd like to do that.
I don't take some take a chance.
Socks a day.
Well,
I don't know.
You know what you gotta do?
You gotta go to Thailand.
That's what you've got to do with this.
Why?
I understand.
If you want to want to find it,
I'm gonna go find a girl.
Appreciates a man,
a man of culture.
Gotta leave Barea chicks are hot there.
And then vice guide to the barrier.
Get one of those hookers out of the $1 hookers.
We'll do it like a dollar.
Like something crazy like that.
Crazy that,
yeah,
that place is fucked up.
Libraries.
The scariest place on earth.
Once force fields are invented,
then I'll go there.
Yeah,
they need to put that thing under that Stephen King Dome Dome that covers the
whole city.
Just drop that mother fucker right down on top of that and keep everybody inside
the Simpsons movie.
Yes.
Let them on the beach.
Yeah,
you need to lock everybody in there.
That's what the fuck is going on there.
It's a former slave colony.
You know for people that don't know about Liberia,
this,
there's a,
there's a documentary called the V.
There's a show called a website called vbs.tv and vbs.tv.
They produce the vice guide to travel and it was just,
and see if there's is insane videos when there's so many of the websites a
little difficult to sift through.
It's Kinda,
it's Kinda Netflix streaming,
Netflix streaming,
streaming Watson,
Liberia one.
It's fucking fantastic,
man.
You don't realize how insane life is over there and on a daily basis they're
dealing with something that's out of the most insane apocalyptic movie of all
time.
If you were living in the camps [inaudible] yeah.
If you were living the way these people were living you literally,
you mean you might as well be living around wild dogs.
You might as well be.
What'd you do to,
I don't know.
My microphone just went crazy.
Some of these people are there,
you know,
there,
there's wildness to them.
You know,
there's some scary shit going down.
A lot of cannibalism,
a lot of mutilations.
You know,
there's a lot of war going on.
There's this one dude that we'd call himself general buck naked thing.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
And he's going to,
that's,
you watch that and you know as soon as the UN leaves,
that guy's going to take off that preacher uniform and it's,
he's going to be a war lord again.
Oh yeah.
So I mean he was drinking innocent blood from babies before war.
He's not
yes.
Just [inaudible] lines and kill a kid,
bring them back,
kill them and eat parts of their heart.
Like what the fuck man.
Did you imagine that scene?
I can imagine if you saw that video online,
would you click that link?
That is the ultimate question.
If there was a video of them killing every time I learned my lesson very early
on.
You have it out there though.
I don't want to see it either.
But there must be,
if these guys have really done it,
it's amazing that this guy is just running around,
you know,
preaching,
it's really kind of incredible.
Especially,
I mean,
he knows,
he's like,
he knows how to survive.
He's a fucking,
uh,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Not a sociopath.
Well,
he's a sociopath,
but like,
no more than any politician.
Like no more than Dick Cheney or,
you know,
it's just so unfortunate,
man.
And you gotta you gotta think this,
this whole situation is so fucked.
It's going to take like hundreds of years to clean up because the life is so
chaotic for these poor people.
And they grow up in this environment,
their program like that and their program to deal with war.
And there's,
you know,
11 and 12 year old kids with guns,
machine guns,
they really all like wild animals.
They're crazy.
You know,
they're living,
they're not,
won't worried about death because everybody dies around them all the time.
Yeah.
It's a really,
really spooky,
spooky environment.
And I don't think people realize it's even going on.
And you know they didn't go in America.
Yeah.
I didn't know.
I didn't know were so soft here.
Soft as puppy shit poppy shit.
In a hot summer day,
man,
when the real shit hits the fan.
That's one of the reasons why I moved to Colorado for a while.
I was convinced I want to go apocalyptic period where I was convinced that La
was just going to fall apart.
It's still as well.
Yeah.
I mean there's a musical chairs,
right?
Yeah.
The music just hasn't stopped fucking
sunset.
The other day there was a bar fight that turned into a full on riot and they
closed down sunset.
Yeah.
You tell me about that.
You were there.
What happened?
Was that the down the street at the comedy store but things,
there's a guy on Twitter called away whoa daily or something like that.
He just pretty much sits there with the police scanner and just talks about she
is West Hollywood.
West Hollywood.
Yeah.
Anyways,
we were sitting at the comedy store and suddenly like hundreds of just cop cars
going by super fast and just helicopters and everything.
We're like,
what the fuck is going on?
So I started looking at Twitter and instant information of Twitter,
which is brilliant,
you know,
so,
uh,
yeah,
I started as a bar fight and then somebody started throwing things at like a
sheriff,
uh,
like bottles and stuff.
And then it became like some kind of a weird small right where they just shut
down all like this big group of bars and went with like,
you know,
canisters,
tear gassed.
And it just turned into huge.
Wow.
Isn't this reception?
Um,
which bar it was by at?
It was by the Roxy and you know,
like the rainbow and all that hard rock section.
Uh,
it was all about,
it was right by there and it just like,
people have videos on the Internet of like what was going and just getting shot
at.
And my friend Katie,
uh,
he,
came back with a canister,
one of the smoke guns that was shot in his direction or something where the
rainbow is.
Yeah.
They just,
it was crazy.
There's some weird videos of,
uh,
of people filming on their iPhones and stuff.
Dude.
Why,
you know,
how come alcohol and and men alcohol and men mix so badly,
but no one ever,
I mean no one ever tries to seriously to shut alcohol down from bars,
but would a,
would a terrible convert combination alcohol and men trying to get pussy.
So like the worst combination ever.
It's amazing that fights don't happen every single night constantly when you're
at a bar.
It's amazing that you can get through a lot of bars without ever fighting.
That's why you just need a bottle of Jaeger meister.
Yeah.
I mean I avoid the man's place where if there's any kind of meat head
contingency that's not a bar I can go to.
Cause I got a fucking
tricky meat has,
can be tricky.
A lot of them don't mean any harm,
but they're used to this fucking way of behaving and Dick slapping each other
and pissing on each other's legs and doing stupid shit.
You know,
they think it's funny.
Well,
people pick me out too.
Like I have,
uh,
punchable face or something.
Like,
I mean I've gotten,
it's just,
you know,
since we're a beard,
I haven't had any,
nobody can get away with it.
That's all it is,
is a lot of it,
you know,
when it comes to those situations,
it's just your,
you unfortunately ran into an asshole that's looking to pick on someone.
Yeah,
yeah.
It is aggression and there's,
yeah,
I can I,
terrible give off whatever vibes of like this guy super nonconfrontational or
something like,
you know,
so I don't even want to be in a position cause like,
yeah,
like,
and the guys are like you like,
I mean you're in goods,
your big dude.
Like it wouldn't,
we're both grown men.
Like it wouldn't be like,
like I feel like if a guy like you beat the shit out of me,
it should,
it should be viewed as like the guy was kicking a puppy down the fucking stairs.
Like it's not a fair,
like a lot of full man like that.
Like,
you know what I mean?
I don't have fucking forearms.
Like I'm not a man,
you know?
I mean exercise.
What would it be like?
It'd be,
well,
I can't fight.
I like,
you know,
I'm not,
yeah,
I can probably do 10 pushups or something.
Wow.
It's born me.
Any guy that chooses to look for a guy to beat up by Todd as a piece of shit and
she's missing the whole point of doing martial arts in the first place.
The whole point of exercising is it'd be free of all the unnecessary instincts
of the body.
You know,
the pent up rage that you makes.
You want to yell in your car and you know,
gives people road rage and you know,
it makes people,
you know,
say insane shit on the Internet.
I mean all that just pent up shit.
Yeah.
The idea of martial arts and exercise is supposed to be that you get all that
stuff out so he could be a much more relaxed.
Well the guy doesn't have to know karate beat me up.
I mean,
any kind of dude with big douchebag,
any big asshole
video you need to own up.
So it's the worst things ever,
man.
There's no need.
We can disagree on things.
I'll go over here.
You go over there.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Bye.
I don't need to win this.
I was just,
I just don't even get worked up about shit.
Like,
I'm so easy to like,
it's like,
all right,
you're right.
I'm wrong.
I'm a faggot.
Like what you,
I don't,
I'm not necessarily top of it.
Not being adduced to you.
Don't be induced to me.
Let's just skate through.
I mean,
I can get mouthy though.
Like,
you know some,
some dudes can,
man,
it's,
I've,
I've been with friends that got drunk and then they say stupid shit to people
and like,
hey,
you're starting something that I'm a part of now and this might be the wings of
the butterfly.
Fucking start the hurricane.
Yeah.
Settle the fuck down out.
Well,
I know.
Yeah.
I don't do that very,
but it's like you have somebody who's fucking with me.
I can,
I know how to push buttons too.
So
yeah.
That's what causes a problem.
If they can't push buttons back,
then they get frustrated
because they can't match wits with you.
They say something stupid.
Yeah.
You have the perfect comeback with a perfect timing.
You're professional comedians in a fair at all.
And then they just want to yell,
fuck you,
kick your ass.
What's funny now?
Funny Man.
Yeah,
yeah.
What have you become?
What have you become and what have you done?
So we're going to have to get you into some neural linguistic programming to try
to refocus your brain and get rid of this Catholic school guilt bullshit,
man.
Yeah.
Well we got together,
if you ever looked into something like that,
I don't really,
John Heffrons,
Ron's a big fan of that in neuro linguistic programming,
trying to have friends and he's like into all sorts of freaky like uh,
enhance your mind type shit.
Like,
oh,
he has like anchors.
He comes up with these things like he'll,
he'll hold his hand in a certain way and when he's killing on stage,
he'll hold his hand a certain way and like remember that moment.
So he then when he goes on stage again numbers,
he holds his hand the second way and he puts himself right back into the place
where he was absolutely destroying onstage.
Like he has like an anchor to that experience.
So he can put himself in the same state.
You know,
that you get a state when you're killing,
when you're onstage and just boom,
you just hit,
you know,
that feeling.
We just,
the pauses are perfect.
You're super relaxed and you're just in the material,
you know,
and he,
he tries to anchor that state in his mind and his consciousness and his memory
and he does something with his hands.
And then,
uh,
once he,
has it,
has it down,
then in his next show,
like right when he's about to go out,
he'll do that same thing with his hand and literally recreate the state or,
you know,
that's the theory
or,
yeah.
But I think that,
well,
yeah,
I don't know.
It sounds,
I mean,
whatever works for whoever,
but I mean,
every situation is different though.
Like whatever you were doing to make that night,
the perfect night of comedy,
this,
this
is a whole different set of people total.
It's a different night.
Different Shit happened today.
Absolutely.
There's definitely,
that's definitely true.
But,
um,
I also think that when I achieve what's attractive to me about it,
and I haven't tried it yet,
but is that,
you know,
it's like,
it's sometimes it's real difficult to figure out where to put your brain when
you're about to go onstage.
Like when you're about to go on stage.
First of all,
I go over my material,
I want to make sure I get this new thing I gotta do.
I've gotta get this out of the way.
I got to do this.
I should pry that.
Should I move this in here?
And which I do that.
But then it's like,
you know how,
what do I do with my happy here?
I'm excited to just wait until I get on stage until I figured out what the fuck
I am.
You know,
what do I do?
Yeah.
At least what he's doing is trying to anchor himself to some really positive
state of mind and then go out and then the ball falls where it may and you know,
he might have to deal with hecklers or it might be a different kind of show,
but at least his state of mind is the optimum state of mind.
So instead of like recreating the exact perfect state,
it's more like,
you know,
he just figures out the right way to be himself when he gets up there,
if that makes any sense.
Yeah,
it's so,
yeah,
it's tough.
I am,
like I said,
I am kind of moody and it's just a bummer when I have to do a show and it's like
I fucking like,
this is the last thing I feel capable of doing.
Not that I never,
like,
I never piss and Moan about having to do a fucking show,
but sometimes it's like,
yeah,
I'm just not,
I'm not that.
I'm not the fucking life of the party guy tonight.
Go on stage and you get a few laughs.
Doesn't it start it,
start a kickback in
sometimes.
I mean it's,
it's always fun and it's,
you know,
but no,
sometimes the whole time onstage I'm just kinda like,
yeah,
I'm just not,
this is,
you know,
I mean,
we're humans.
Like,
it's like,
yeah,
it's just not that much fun tonight.
And I'm not feeling like,
you know,
or is it the crowd or is it given,
it's a combination.
Like I can be in one of those like depressed,
just fucking,
I don't want to do this Sunday night show and I get on stage and there's like
that,
you know,
the crowds like,
no,
we're good.
We're here to fucking,
this is,
we're not just going to be a bunch of fucking shit.
We're here,
we all want it to be here.
This isn't an office party or whatever.
And,
and then you're like,
oh yeah,
then if fucking,
yeah,
that changes everything because it's a total give and take.
I mean,
cause like if I'm in a great fucking mood and the crowd just like we're not,
we don't really give,
we wandered in here somehow,
you know,
like,
right.
Which can happen.
Yeah,
it does happen a lot.
So it's like,
oh,
well this isn't a mutually beneficial thing then.
Do you,
um,
do you have crowds now where they're coming out specifically to see you and you
know the difference?
Not really.
Not Crowds.
There are people groups in the crusade.
Yeah.
A handful of people who know me from Doug I to,
I opened for Doug for a few years,
um,
spy kids to buy kids too.
Um,
it just kind of being,
I mean,
I haven't been doing it super long.
Um,
how long were you doing it?
About eight years.
Uh,
started in know too.
Yeah.
I,
that's
one crazy.
If you were like in school you'd have a fucking Phd,
but with comedy,
like Ram,
you need to put in some years kid.
Yeah,
no,
I'm still figuring it out and yeah,
I W I was,
I was like 29 30 when I started and it's like,
fuck,
why didn't I get like,
I was just having too much fun goofing off.
I was like,
ah,
I don't know.
I didn't,
I wish I started when I was like 22 or something.
Yeah.
But you know what you did.
That's the most important thing is that you did forget about all that other
bullshit and still I was goofing off the whole time,
but I wasn't.
I think the good thing is you don't have this body of work from the past that
like sucks
back when you're stupid and they go on Youtube and man,
I've got some comedy out there.
There's some,
some video of me from when I was 25 at Rascal's Comedy Club in New Jersey.
It's terrible.
I have a luscious head of hair though.
I'm so jealous of my hair.
When my hair started really fallen out,
I was like just starting to fall out back then and um,
there was like,
the is silly.
I was all skinny.
I didn't lift weights back then or anything and I was like looking,
I was like,
God,
it's just awful comedy and it's attached to me forever.
Yeah,
I guess like,
I mean this stuff,
I even know I was 29 or 30 when I started.
I mean,
yeah,
there's some pretty,
there's not great shit I was doing.
I had,
it was
a lot of shit actually.
I bought a diary a better than beat when I was 21.
But yeah,
no,
there's nothing that's like completely appalling.
I've got a,
when I was 21,
man,
I,
uh,
there's a couple of times that are recorded myself and I recorded the second
time I was ever on stage.
I have it back there somewhere on a cassette.
Wow.
And it's set on it just audio tremendously bad.
It's so horrible out.
Painful to listen to my accent makes me want to kick myself in the halls.
It's just,
it's so,
or is it just a thick Boston accent?
A little bit,
yeah.
The Boston accent and just,
I didn't have anything to say mean.
What the fuck do you have to say when you're 21,
you're just like,
look at me.
And then people are like,
why do you want me to look at you?
And then you go,
yeah,
okay,
hold on.
I have to figure that out.
Yeah.
Get Way ahead of yourself.
You go and look at me first before you have anything to say.
You know,
when you're 21,
I mean if you're,
you right now you're,
you know,
36 years old,
I was 30,
37 you go to a comedy club and some 21 year old goes on stage,
you know,
and you're like,
I mean,
come on rent really w how much have you got?
Really?
It's,
I mean,
and I tried not to prejudge people,
although I can tell onsite whether or not somebody is fucking funny or not.
You can just tell it like every now and then you're surprised.
You're like,
oh,
I thought that guy was really gonna suck.
Just judging by the way he looks and you can tell like,
um,
but no,
I tried to keep an open mind and yeah,
a lot of times it's like heard that,
but like it's just,
people just don't like a lot of these younger guys just don't have a knowledge
of like,
it's like you're not the first guy to ever fucking split the atom on this.
Like,
you know,
you don't think I can.
Yeah.
I think of a good example.
They have a knowledge of stand up.
You sort of have to have like a body of stand up that you've listened to before
you just jump in.
Yeah.
Get familiar with some stuff.
Even like,
you know,
I mean I listened to a ton of,
I have a bunch of old comedy albums that I,
I like listen to them on vinyl and I've had them since I was a kid.
I mean I collect them still,
you know,
I buy them.
It's a cheap hobby to have.
You can get comedy lps for like three bucks a piece.
Uh,
but even just like,
yeah,
I can't think of,
well yeah,
you should know like older shit because it's like you're not the first guy.
A lot of this stuff that you think is brilliant.
It's like,
well fucking Sam Kinison had a whole thing about it or,
uh,
or there's five guys working the road right now doing a thing about the
Starbucks coffee cup sizes being called different names than a small,
medium and large.
Like,
yeah,
come on man.
Yeah,
but it's all,
I guess you just figure it out.
Well,
I can understand someone just doing their own version of it until they sort of
get their feet out from under him or get their feet under him.
You know,
when they're just,
you know,
when you're doing an open mic nights and shit,
I get all that.
But once you actually start doing gigs,
you know,
she started,
going places,
then you should probably know what other people are doing,
you know?
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
I mean sometimes
you can't be doing a Lenny Bruce joke and not knowing,
oh no,
because there was a dude that,
uh,
I used to know back in Boston has,
is he's a great writer.
He's a really funny guy.
He didn't,
he didn't steal it.
He wrote it on his own,
but it was a Lenny Bruce line.
Now I'm like,
man,
you should,
you got to got to know about that one.
It was about gay people and gay people,
gay being illegal,
dig this man gay.
Being gay is illegal.
So what do they do?
They take you and they put you in prison with a bunch of men want to have sex
with you.
Yeah.
You know,
and that was Lenny Bruce like in you know,
whatever's in 1950 or something like that dude reinvented it in 1990 you know I
had no we just did.
Well that's going to happen and I mean people are going to tell you,
although sometimes like there've been a couple,
there's one thing in particular that I was kind of confused as to why nobody
told me I was doing a bit like I had again when I started,
it was a lot of fucking diarrhea jokes and stuff and I had a,
I had a joke about Tgi fry,
like just,
it was basically a diary,
a chunk,
but it started with Tgi Friday cause I got wicked like bad diarrhea from Tgi
Friday's one time.
And Yeah,
just that was like the got me into my diarrhea thing.
And then I was in Philly working at the club there and I didn't have enough time
to eat.
I either,
there's a rite aid across the street.
I bought hot pockets from the rite aid and heated him up in the microwave,
ate them and like the worst fucking diarrhea again.
So I just changed it in my bit.
Like it's like,
well,
I'll update my diarrhea chunk to the last thing it gave me diarrhea was hot
pockets and uh,
but Jim Gaffigan has like this huge hot pockets chunk.
I didn't,
I saw it on TV one day.
Like I saw his,
you know,
I turned on TV,
comedy central zone.
I was like,
oh,
I'll watch some of this guy.
And he goes into this like 15 minute hot pockets chunk.
And I'm like,
how did nobody ever tell me that this guy?
Like,
I mean it's not like we're doing this,
but he talks about how they give you a diary in,
I don't know.
It's just weird.
Like I think you
paths don't cross your fans and his fans and your people in his people.
Well it seems like it's a pretty famous kind of bit of finger though,
even though I didn't,
I don't know the bit though.
But I know he does a bit,
this is a famous sitters.
I don't know the bit,
but I know he hasn't.
Yeah,
it's that famous.
It's like his signature,
like put them on them.
You know,
putting them up into that.
He's an interesting case.
You know,
he's an interesting guy,
you know,
it's like super squeaky clean and nice and you know,
tasks for tick character thing too.
I've been talking to other community and friends who are like kind of,
you know,
on my peers,
where you know,
I still feel like I'm struggling with like
really fucking dialing in,
like finding my voice,
getting into that like zone of like,
you know,
like Doug or like just really knowing who you are and what,
like I don't feel like I have any strong opinions on anything sometimes.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
yeah,
I'm kind of like,
you know,
don't,
yeah.
It's like I,
it's like,
well,
I don't want to ruffle any feathers.
You know?
It's like,
well then that's going to be,
oh,
you're gonna be a great comedian Sunday.
Yeah.
Just get on stage.
What are you guys are,
I just want to make sure everybody's cool with everything I say because I don't
want anybody on that man.
Yeah.
That's kind of fun.
Still Cut.
But I think that the character,
like Gaffigan has that.
And even I was watching some of,
I saw part of Louis C [inaudible] hilarious,
uh,
thing.
They showed it on comedy central the other night and I fall asleep halfway
through now because it was boring.
Ice.
Just
exhausted.
Don't even say that.
A man shouldn't even say that.
Oh,
well I fell asleep halfway through,
bro.
Watch that.
While it's great.
No,
totally.
I mean,
it's,
I didn't mean that.
Uh,
why,
why?
Yeah.
I,
I didn't sleep the night before and just as soon as I laid on a couch,
I fell asleep in the middle of k one dynamite.
Like a bitch fell asleep in the middle of fucking cage fighting.
I'm watching [inaudible] try to kill each other with their bare hands and feet
and knees.
You're like,
you know,
I'm fucking in the counseling.
Well,
yeah,
that's not,
I mean,
actually Louis Ck is fantastic.
Louis Ck so good that I don't hear anybody ever say anything like,
but Louis C,
k s hilarious.
So there's not like one comic that I know that it's a dissenter that's like not
that good.
Yeah.
Everybody's like,
God,
it's so cool to be around,
you know,
at a time where there's a guy like this is doing a new hour of crazy new shit
every year.
Dissect it.
And you know what I was seeing because I like I,
I've been talking to other people about how like,
or what I've been noticing,
it's like,
oh,
it's like this character,
like Gaffigan asked the guy who talks to himself like this,
right?
And like,
even Louis C k a guy who's just kind of like writing great ship.
Yeah.
He even has little like,
did,
did the dude,
like he has these little kind of things that are just part of his personality
and the way he talks where he's found his voice,
but it's like big
and you know,
he could say a sentence without writing any joke to,
it's just like the way it's like,
it's just all these elements are combined to like,
just make this perfect.
That's what makes a great comedian.
It's like you're like this definitive personality.
Like people can do impressions of you.
And that's I guess where like I feel,
I don't feel like I'm,
yeah,
I like,
I can make people laugh.
I can go on stage and keep people entertained all night,
but it's like,
well,
what's,
what's my fucking gimmick?
Like Nadia,
you know,
that sounds weird,
but even like Benson dug beds,
who was talking about that in some interview I saw them where like,
it's like,
oh,
the pot thing just kind of naturally happened.
And before that he was,
he was just a funny,
well-respected comedian.
But then once you have like some thing where that identifies you,
uh,
which uh,
yeah,
I don't feel like,
you know,
you said a phrase something like you can't,
do they get the beard out?
Yeah,
no,
I mean it's like a,
you need to get her done.
I think it's just a big of like,
you know,
doing it fucking cause like yeah,
like you were saying you'd have,
I could be a doctor if I went to fucking school for eight years,
but you would put so much more effort into being a doctor then you do in the
being a comedian.
Comedians for the most part,
we're pretty fucking lazy about writing and about performing and about,
you know,
like really going over material and correcting in and trying to enhance it.
And Yeah,
I record all my sessions,
but I only listened to half of them ever.
It's like that fucking torture to listen to yourself,
but that's the really the way to develop new material.
Whenever I have a new bit and I pause and I'd go over it and I,
I listened to the recording and then I go over the way it's written,
the way it's said,
I always can make it better.
I can always enhance it for sure.
It's always beneficial.
It is.
I,
I'm the worst with it too.
Like I have fucking drawers full of Lego pieces of paper and notebooks and it's
like,
I just write this shit down and then I throw the notebook in a drawer.
It's like,
why don't you flip through this shit a little more often and and watch yourself.
yeah.
All right.
What is it doing?
I'm not doing anything.
That's what it did earlier.
Remember the headphones near though?
Whoa.
That's crazy.
Well,
that was the loudest fucking seven.
That's weird because we're sitting here the whole time.
They're on your head,
but you took the headphones off.
What did you do?
I just,
yeah,
I just took my head off phones off and you put them near the microphone back
crazy.
No,
no,
no.
You were up there when it,
when it's still doing it back there.
Oh,
start started over there and then that's weird.
That's what I'm saying.
It's kind of weird.
That sucks.
[inaudible] plugged in,
right?
[inaudible] good.
Yeah.
All right.
Anyway,
where were you?
Oh,
Geez.
Your thing,
you voice,
not even your gimmick.
I know what you're saying.
You just kind of,
yeah.
I don't feel like you're 100% satisfied with the evolution of you as like you're
not representative of who you can be on stage and you don't really know.
You're just kind of them back and forth.
Yeah.
And it's,
yeah,
pretty was very honest man.
You know,
there was,
um,
there's been many times in my life where my act is like changed or who I felt
about myself on stage and you know,
how I performed is changed and most of it's depending on how much focus on
putting on it,
you know,
and who you're hanging out with,
what you're,
you know,
it's just,
yeah,
I mean I think you could definitely lose a grip on it.
You know?
That's the thing about comedy,
it's like you can start off in a good way.
I mean,
how many times you ever seen a guy who starts out really good and like,
this kid's got potential and then somewhere along the line they just skid out.
We get lazy.
They wrote,
yeah,
20 good minutes.
Yeah,
exactly.
23.
And it's like,
well,
you're 42 now.
And he really needed to be doing same joke.
That was funny.
Yeah,
that's brutal.
That's the most painful part of it.
Yeah.
It's hard for guys to let go of Shit that they know will work and try new things
that no one's ever heard before.
They have a chance.
Well,
and even watching yourself,
like I submitted for a half hour special on comedy central last year and I had,
I recorded,
you know,
I recorded some sets obviously,
and I had to send them a DVD and watching just from watching those DVDs,
I realized like,
I never fucking watch myself.
I improved fucking like five jokes just by sitting there and watch you go,
oh wait,
this is a much better tag than what I've been saying for the last eight months.
After that fucking joke.
Sometimes you forget tags.
You go and listen to you like Jesus.
That's the perfect,
oh,
that's the best part of the fucking joke all the time too.
You're like,
how did I fucking forget that little aside that made that joke fucking good for
me.
And that's it.
The difference between you and,
um,
I and comics and you know,
people that go for the PhDs,
they put in a lot more fucking effort and time.
But the thing about funny,
as funny as got to also be connected to fun,
like it's very difficult to have a fucking complete shit life and be funny on
stage.
Like you don't feel like funny.
Yeah.
There's gotta be some fun involved.
And the reality is when you're in college or you're working for your phd or
your,
you know,
involved in some crazy business where you have to work 16 hours a day,
there's not a whole lot of fun going on.
There's not a whole lot of humor in any of that,
you know.
And for a comic,
a certain amount of you almost has to be lazy.
Like I've never met like a great comic that at least one point in time didn't
struggle with extreme laziness and procrastination and self indulgence and the
need to just masturbate all day because,
you know,
you're just too silly.
Yeah.
Because yeah,
candidate feels good and you're like,
you get obsessed with it and you're like,
fuck it.
Yeah,
we're all like,
I mean,
I know at least.
Yeah.
I didn't like bedtime and like anything and now it's like,
oh,
now we're adults.
Like we're are kind of a bunch of fucking overgrown kids who are like,
I can go to bed,
whatever the fuck I went.
Yeah,
I fall asleep in front of the check off five times today.
It's a shitty retail email.
The fucking,
I'll return those emails tomorrow.
What I was doing is I get my writing done and then when I get my writing done,
I'm satisfied.
I've got over a thousand words,
I've got some really good shit there.
I like what I'm saying at a thousand words or whatever,
whatever I feel is enough.
Then I'll just start surfing the internet and I started watching documentaries,
so I'll be watching some fucking galactic void documentary about where they
think,
why don't you just tell her nursery,
why don't you do like laptop in bed then?
Yeah,
I don't sleep alone.
That light going on and knowing people,
I think that's rude and I don't like when I'm in my office,
that's when I write my best shit.
You know?
That's my,
that's my area,
which is where we filmed this podcast.
Right.
You know,
it's like this,
um,
you know,
I,
this is my spot.
You know what I mean?
I got this spot nailed.
I know exactly what's going on.
Come on.
Refrigerator right here.
My coconut juice,
my computer right here.
I'm not going anywhere.
So any ideas that I have,
if I'm watching a documentary,
I want to be right here and comfortable with,
they can come out as easy as possible.
You know what I love,
man,
there's fucking Evernote thing that,
uh,
if you ever seen that,
do you know what that is?
It's an application for the iPhone I've been at through your phone too.
You have a droid?
Is that a droid?
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm sure they have it for George.
It's amazing,
man.
You can take websites,
any idea that you have that you see on a website like,
Whoa,
the scientist,
just new discovery,
you know,
inside every black hole is,
the possibility of a new universe,
you know,
and you're like,
Whoa,
I've got to remember that.
What would this everquest thing,
all you have to do is like press.
You can get it,
you get the webpage,
the webpage loads up like the text version of the webpage,
you know even with photos and everything loads up on your,
your Evernote and you save it and you have that article.
Anything that you have an idea,
you have an idea like you have to write you a you,
you,
you write this down in your little phone and you put it in Evernote and when you
put it in Evernote,
it syncs up,
but it syncs up with your home computer.
It syncs up with whatever else you got and you got a laptop wherever you want to
keep the notes for a comic,
it's fucking in valuable.
Yeah.
So like if you're writing a new bit and you don't have time to transfer to your
phone,
it doesn't matter.
You just turn on your new phone at the comedy club and go,
Oh,
there's the bit.
I was just writing
that was working on a bit at Sal's the other night and right before I got up I
said,
Oh shit,
I forgot to get that,
retrieve it from Evernote.
So I go to Evernote,
retrieve it,
Bam,
copy and paste it,
put it in my notes,
went over the ideas,
hit the beats of the jokes.
Boom.
You go on stage and it's like you can keep all your notes,
all of it online all the time.
Yeah,
and you could access it as you get a new phone,
like say if you're fucking iPhone falls in the toilet and you're like,
fuck,
will you go to the apple store and you get a new phone?
Well your new phone will sync up and boom,
all those notes.
We'll be right back when they were so fucking this shit dude for right now.
It's the shit.
The beautiful thing about it is that it's not just text,
it's text and pictures and anything else.
It's like,
yeah,
you can save a whole webpage.
Like you want to read a webpage,
you could read the whole thing,
man.
Just saves it right to your phone,
save the right to your laptop and you sync up with any number of devices that
you want.
You got a laptop,
you've got a home computer,
boom,
boom.
So for,
for comics,
like when you find out like some crazy story online or there's some new subject
you have to talk about.
Boom.
It's so easy to save it.
We'll look it up right now.
I mean I have to change the,
uh,
I have to change the nine volt battery that might [inaudible] tongue on,
put your tongue on it.
See if it's still hot.
I remember that when used to do that with a little bit id,
nine volts.
Yeah.
Get that jolt.
I said,
son,
what is that?
What are you doing yourself when you do that?
Does that give any cancer?
Probably.
I think it's just the little electric charge.
That's it.
Yeah.
Hope without,
fuck tried that first.
There's a comedian in Austin who's got a joke about who,
who was the first guy to try a pineapple?
Like the guys,
that guy.
Well I don't even remember how it goes but it's funny cause it's like the most
uninviting.
Like let's eat this thing.
And he's like,
oh there's a,
the first guy that ate the pineapple was like a hero and there's a guy like
right next to him with a pine cone.
Like fuck so close.
That's funny.
Yeah.
He's a funny dude.
Austin's a funny place man.
There's a lot of good comedy that comes out of Austin.
It's a great scene.
It's,
yeah.
I mean I,
I stayed there for,
it's an easy place to live,
man.
Especially when you start working the road.
Cause I just,
I started working the road from there just doing shit,
shit,
Midwest stuff.
Just opening from random guys before Doug picked me up and I started going with
him.
It was like,
you've got to kind of a dark act.
Do you ever get guys that tell you,
hey,
you know,
don't do this bit or don't,
don't swear too much or don't get too creepy or no,
I have no currently no,
no.
Like when you were middle and for guys when you're going on the road,
ah,
you know,
I don't remember like there was no real,
nothing sticks out with people going like,
if you fucking tell that
we've had these conversations before about guys taking guys on the road with
them and telling them like what bits to do,
what are you taking the guy on the road with you?
Yeah,
it's Kinda Kinda twisted,
but I did like random dudes that had sound cues and costume change clothes or
beyond that.
I think they featured,
no,
but I'd be the feature act where like,
no thought goes into comedy booking.
It's like Sioux Falls,
South Dakota,
Brendan Walsh.
And then like,
uh,
you know,
there's a guy called the midnight swinger who's a nice guy,
but how is this a fucking show?
Like the guys all like,
he wears like a fucking Vegasy style thing.
He's got a big Johnny Bravo or whatever,
that cartoon guy,
the big Hairdo and,
and his act is like,
you know,
he does a bunch of sound cues and shit at the end.
I mean get standing ovations.
Everybody loves him,
but it's like,
well why am I opening for him?
Like if anybody in the crowd likes me,
they're probably not going to like him.
Vice versa,
if people were here to see the singing and dancing guy who's like,
again,
super good dude and like Stan,
I never got a standing ovation in my life and he would get them six nights a
week.
But those guys are freak out and go,
why the fuck am I not on TV?
America loves me.
These crowds love me.
I lot of them,
I don't know guys like that who have like kind of those big,
you know,
kind of clothes or things and really the whole lobby,
they seem,
a lot of them seem to be happy with like doing like little rooms in Vegas here
and there.
They'll go on a cruise ship and they'll really,
I,
I mean,
I don't know.
That's kind of get the idea that some of them are pretty happy with like,
Oh,
you know,
I can make,
like it's,
it's not easy to make 80 or a hundred grand a year,
you know.
And if you can do that just by doing like,
you know,
kind of be rooms headlining,
be rooms selling,
like a lot of them have like some kind of t shirt or something they sell and
they'll fucking make more than they're getting paid from the club that week off.
They're like,
who farted tee shirts?
Well I know a lot.
I have a lot of friends that uh,
when they go on the road,
like they,
you know,
they run into trouble where people don't want a middle and forum.
Like Joey,
nobody wants Joey Diaz middle and for ya or Ari,
you know,
there's a lot of dudes who won't,
don't want a guy like that to middle for him.
You know,
like if,
you know,
there's,
students had complain about him,
like it goes up at the comedy store cause he's just,
he's dirty and it's ranching.
It's funny and people think for some reason that they get into,
someone gets into this mindset,
you can't pull them out of it.
So I'll say I don't want him going on before me.
Like really?
Like what the fuck?
Come on.
That's crazy.
I don't mind anybody gone on before me with the exception of like famous guy,
like you know,
like I was at the laugh factory one time and was about to go up and you're like,
Carlos,
Mitzi is here,
he wants to go out and this isn't like a,
you know,
weird Carlos Man.
See his story.
He went on and he did like,
you know,
20 minutes.
It wasn't one of those things where he did three hours and I had to drive home.
Like he,
you know,
did like 15 or 20 minutes.
But the crowd was pretty psyched to see him and,
and you know,
he had a good set but then I had to go up and it was like,
yeah,
everybody's kind of still just getting over the fucking buzz from seeing that
dude.
Like nobody's listening.
Those are good for you though,
man.
I did a lot of those sets and uh,
the at the comedy store and I think those sets really taught me a lot about
grabbing the audience and about,
you know,
just just going out there and getting into it and doing your shit.
Cause there was a bunch of times where I'd gone after,
um,
Martin Lawrence.
Oh yeah.
And the crowd would be,
you know,
90% black too and Martin Lawrence would uh,
get offstage do like,
you know,
he did.
He was,
and so he'd do like a long set and destroy and then bring me up and that nobody
wanted to hear a fucking word.
I was saying.
I did it with dice clay.
I used to have to go on after dice clay a lot.
I did a with a bunch of times with prior when Richard Pryor was really sick.
Oh I went on right after.
I'm like,
oh,
for like five weeks a wheelchair.
I've talked about this,
but it's a pretty crazy story.
He was,
he was so sick that they used to have to turn the mic up.
Oh Shit.
Like it was so hot that it was so hot because he couldn't talk loud and he would
just be sitting in his,
in his chair.
They would have to carry them onto the stage and he would be drinking and just
get fucked up and just talk and unstated.
You understand a word.
He was barely,
man.
I always love pussy.
There's no joke.
Yeah.
It's like he's,
his faculties were diminished substantially and yet he was on stage talking and
people like had this weird feeling that it was like,
it was,
there was a feeling of sadness.
There was like a feeling of,
of,
you know,
here we're paying tribute to a great legend of comedy,
but man,
look at them now.
Like it's,
it's hard to watch.
And so then they would,
they would bring me up and,
uh,
the,
the uh,
piano guy,
Jeff would go.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
we have another very funny comedian.
You might've seen him on news radio.
Get up for Joe.
I might've,
you know what?
No,
I don't even think I was on news radio at the time.
I think I'm lying.
I think I was on hardball who was a show that was on Fox.
It was a baseball show that was on Fox and nobody gave a fuck about that show.
It didn't matter who you were.
Anyway,
man,
you were going on after Richard Pryor and they have to carry him.
They have to carry him through the audience.
Yeah.
So they're walking him.
It's chewy and some other dude are carrying him through the audience cause and
it takes a long time to get them through.
It takes like five minutes,
like no bullshit.
Like they have to be really slow because they're sort of half walking him,
half carrying him.
Right.
So the audience is a standing ovation from Mr Pryor and then you get onstage and
you have to crack jokes while Richard Pryor is crawling.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The creeping.
He can't even control his body.
How long did he do that for?
I did a five weeks.
Wow.
Did a bunch of shows.
He did a bunch of shows.
Yeah,
it was weird,
man.
It was weird to watch.
I only watched a couple of them.
I couldn't take it anymore.
I was just freaking me out man.
You know,
cause I would,
when I was a little kid I saw live and that sunset strip light,
that's one of the reasons why I wanted to do comedy,
that that first video my parents took me to see in the movie theater.
And I remember sitting in that theater laughing so fucking hard thinking how
incredible it was that this guy is just talking and he's so funny.
And I thought all the funny movies I'd seen like stripes and all these different
things that were great,
but they were never as funny as this.
Like this was the old I looked around,
I looked in the theater,
I was watching people like falling out of their seat,
walking back and forth laughing.
And I was just thinking this is the most incredible thing ever.
And then they go from that to
yes.
I mean the whole room is just crackling with this hot microphone sounds.
His glasses clinking his,
you know,
his ice in his glass always loved posey cause it never did no bad me.
Like it was like he had no jokes.
He had nothing to say.
It's all just like polite laughter.
Yeah,
it's,
Huh,
Huh?
No,
the imaginary looks horrible.
That's so sad.
The worst thing.
Greatest in my opinion,
if I had to pick one guy who was like,
you know,
the,
the shining,
you know,
example of what's possible.
So much better than anyone before him.
Yeah,
I know.
So influential.
It's prior.
I mean he's so much better than anybody before him,
you know,
and hitting the high notes and doing that style of comedy is like sort of
friendly,
Raunchy,
honest,
insightful comedy.
So lovable,
so vulnerable.
Like everything about him was just,
he was like the,
you know,
at the time he was like for sure the greatest standup comedian ever.
And so to go from that to watching them just like his body just physically
betraying him,
you know,
it's like so hard to do and then they have to do comedy.
Like it's,
it's such a double whammy.
It's jokes about,
yeah,
I would make jokes about it.
Like,
okay,
Richard Pryor and then who is this unknown White Douche bag?
You know,
who,
oh my,
what the fuck am I doing up here?
Yeah.
And I would say,
you know,
hey,
that's exactly what I'm thinking too,
to just get through this as they slowly did show her.
I still do like weird one night or things that,
uh,
this guy books,
these shows like that are all about an hour away and uh,
or the embars yeah,
they're in bars.
Uh,
Barstow's a rough after data one.
Um,
do you have to do one win tonight?
Where are you going to be at?
Uh,
Newport beach or something like that?
Do you want to tell people so they can go?
Oh,
sure.
hold,
I'll tell you the name of the place.
It's called e p.
Dot.
If you don't,
we did a,
we all did sales comedy hall the other night.
I loved that place.
Isn't that a cool little spot?
You know?
Yeah.
It's got a great vibe.
I did,
but what I was doing this show like the Monday or Tuesday,
Wednesday before Christmas this year.
So it's like,
it's a few days before Christmas.
That guy's like,
hey,
let 50 bucks.
I'm like,
yeah.
All right.
And,
uh,
we got there.
It was just a whole Christmas.
Don't borrow was just full of people that were there for a Christmas party.
And there were like eight people at the front who came for the comedy show,
but it was just like a coffee.
And I hate,
this is one of my biggest pet peeves,
like when comedians get these bar shows together and some guys are just there to
get a drink,
you can't force comedy down people's throats.
I'm going to guys like,
Hey,
fuck,
go,
hey,
there's a show going on over here.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
don't get on the guy's car.
He's just having a beer man.
Like,
uh,
so yeah,
it's like,
well,
it's all these people were here for Christmas party.
They don't care what the fuck I'm saying these other eight people are kind of
having a,
you know,
getting a kick out of it.
But I'd like very early on,
and I'm doing,
I'm taping a TV thing this week,
so I was like,
well,
it'll be a chance to try and run through that material.
Which like,
no way.
Right.
I was like,
fuck.
And,
uh,
so I just said when I was up there,
I was like,
it doesn't matter what the fuck I say does it like,
no,
nobody's even going to acknowledge it.
I said,
I said like I ran a baby over on my way there and like it made me horny.
So I went back and jerked off on the baby and stole his wallet and found out
where it lived and went and face fuck,
that's mom.
And it just like just started saying all this random shit and like the people
who were paying attention,
we're getting a kid cause like it did not,
not one eyebrow raised from the Christmas party.
And then for the last seven,
cause the guy wanted me to do a certain amount of time and it's like,
yeah,
it's one of those gigs where it's like,
well if I don't do the full fucking time,
you might not give you the 50 bucks.
So I looked at my phone,
I was recording it at a,
or maybe I was,
maybe I turned the recorder off at a certain point.
But,
uh,
I saw I had like seven minutes left.
And I just said,
I was like,
well,
I have seven minutes left.
I'm just gonna make noises for the last seven minutes.
If anybody has any suggestions,
I mean I'll try to make whatever noise you telling me to make.
I did a car alarm,
like you know the full run of the car alarm ain't took some weird suggestions,
did like a tiger tiger doing something and I wound up going,
it's great middle of it.
But I did all the time.
But it was,
that's very liberating when,
I dunno,
I hadn't been in a experience like that in a really long time where I was like,
oh this is fucking like impossible.
What's that die?
It was one of the most,
it was pretty fun actually because I was like,
well,
once I realized I was like,
okay,
I'm not going to get to run through this fucking set list that I'm trying to get
together.
And it's like,
really nobody's paying attention like,
and then just to start just saying whatever fucked weird shit comes into your
head.
I did this gig recently in of the worst hell Gig I've done a long time and I did
look a year ago,
that Twitter thing,
remember we did it wouldn't dove Dove David off.
Nick Foun me and was there another person?
There was a post,
I forget the host's name,
I apologize.
But it was something for Twitter and they did it in a rock bar and the acoustics
were the worst acoustics ever.
Every word you said was echoed back and was totally incomprehensible.
No one had any idea what you were saying.
There was a very narrow area in the front of the stage where you could talk and
that's it.
The people in the front of the stage like directly in front of you,
you know six feet to the left,
six feet to the right.
They can hear you.
Yeah.
But everyone else on the sides,
it had no idea what the fuck you were saying.
I was literally five feet from the stage while,
while dove was on stage and I couldn't understand a word he was saying
[inaudible] button just warehouse.
How big was the venue for this?
It was weird cause it's like a night club dance floor.
So the situation,
it wasn't set up for talking now and then on top of that the whole time doves on
stage,
they're blowing smoke on.
I'm not kidding.
Like he's covered in smoke because a band was on beforehand so the smoke is
blowing down on him.
You can't hear a word he's fucking saying and is at one point in time we turns
and looks at me and Nixon and on the side he's like,
what can fuck is this this kid even be real like it was so spectacularly shitty.
Lee set up and it just,
it didn't even seem like it'd be real and through and went up into the same
thing and then I went up into the same thing,
which is how we both like people on the side of us.
We're just looking at us like anyone on the side of you,
they would just look at you.
They have no idea what the fuck you were saying.
Boone told me one of the craziest fucking stories a couple of weeks ago.
I can't even do it justice Dick if you're listening,
Collin.
Uh,
no,
it was just like a nightmare stage story.
Like it blew my fucking mind.
Like it was in San Francisco and like basically the waitresses all wound up
getting like the crowd hated him and then like the waitresses were like these
roller derby ish type Bettie page chicks or whatever.
And they wound up like rushing him on stage and one like held them down while
the other one tried to pull his pants down.
It's,
it's honestly,
it's the most fucked up story I've ever Nick Thune Nick Thune.
Yeah.
Recently,
a few years ago,
I think it was in San Francisco because we were talking,
we got on the topic.
I mean,
I don't mean to,
I hope I'm not fucking being gossipy.
Uh,
I don't know.
It's weird,
but it was like,
no,
it wasn't a club,
but he was saying that,
you know,
um,
yeah,
I don't want to say,
I don't know if it's weird enough,
but like somebody who books the clubs in,
in San Francisco was at that show and he's like,
hands.
I was like,
the biggest nightmare.
He,
you know,
practically got booed off stage and then all these people tried to rape them on
onstage.
Wow.
But like,
so I don't think he gets booked at like the punchline or like he doesn't get
booked up there and he's like,
wow,
she was at that show where that happened.
And I don't know,
I guess,
you know,
they're not a fan or I that's weird.
I don't,
cause I'm,
I could be wrong,
but uh,
but I know it happened in San Francisco at some weird menu and it was the mo and
I'm forgetting parts.
Like he,
it was a pretty interesting story and I feel bad.
I was hanging out with nick the other day.
Uh,
we went and like walked dogs and we're hanging out in the park with the Chelsea
Peretti too.
And I don't,
we're just all fucking goofing around.
I forget how it happened,
but I wound up tweeting congratulations to nick through newest cast member on
Saturday night live,
but it just totally joking and we,
like,
we decide,
I don't know,
we were talking about starting a rumor or something.
Right.
And that fucking thing spiraled out of control so fast.
I feel bad.
I mean I've taught,
me and nick have talk cause like he started getting emails and it's this Twitter
thing is fucking scared.
Like people were saying,
fuck you.
You're not,
no,
no.
They're saying congratulations.
We always knew you.
I mean it's just the worst like,
and he's like,
and he's getting,
he's got to be like,
it's pulled down by Derby bitches.
Well that was a,
that was years ago.
But yeah,
I feel bad about that little hoax that
Shaffir are.
You should feel went on this a long tour.
Him and Tripoli and a couple other guys,
they went on this long tour and after he came back he said one thing for sure I
learned from this.
No more bars.
That's it.
You said it's not done before but bars.
Yeah,
no more.
Freddy Soto used to say that.
We still always talk about it,
that people would offer him gigs and it would go no thank you.
That's me and Stan hope started working together was when we really started
working together.
The bars.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean,
when he was booking,
shit just threw my space when he was like,
I'm not working any more clubs.
They would just put on my space.
If you have a place,
tell me where it is.
We'll work out a door deal.
And Yeah,
we did.
We did some fucking shitty place,
like you know,
place with that stages.
I mean they were all,
it was a fun experience.
But the outside place in Vegas,
the outside place.
Yeah.
Some dude was shelling,
having shows in his backyard and I did it.
I don't know if Doug did it,
but I know a couple of comics like guys would names did it.
I think the guy emailed me or that sounds familiar,
but no,
I never did this to doing it,
but it was like,
you know what?
I could do the palms.
Yeah,
why am I doing?
You're crazy in the back yard.
You might be nuts,
man,
and I'm connected to you.
You fucking crackpot.
But it's a great,
great idea.
You know,
kid just decide it's going to set up his own comedy club.
He was like,
you know,
I'll charge 20 bucks at the door.
Everybody's packed into my backyard.
I've got a stage and a PA and everyone's enthusiastic and we're all drinking
beer,
other coolers and shit.
Like on paper it sounds awesome.
But then the other girl who is this crazy ass asshole yeah,
bringing me into his backyard.
And that's kind of the stuff that's a big difference between Doug and I.
Like he kind of thrives on that shit where it's like a crazy,
insane idea.
I'm on board and,
well,
I was hanging out at his house back when the,
the homeless people living on his front porch and then the homeless woman wound
up Stan,
but stabbing the homeless man and like,
you know,
and Doug had all these films of her.
In one of them,
she had blood all over her hands after she stabbed her boyfriend and she's
sitting on her knees.
So she's kneeling and she's looking at her hands and she goes,
I'm a cunt.
I'm a whole.
I'm a content,
I'm a whore.
I'm a come to my heart.
She's saying on this craziest while she's got this guy's blood on her hands and
they take him away and you know,
he has to go get stitched up and he survives.
But he's got,
you got fucking stab,
you know,
and she goes to jail and these were people live in on Doug Front porch.
She just had them homeless people or audio tape.
I'd hang out with them.
I'd go over Doug's house to drag and be like me and Doug and say,
you know a couple of friends.
It's a fucking homeless people so far.
It was so weird.
He's so,
I mean he invites the chaos,
but I think God damn dude,
I understand what you're doing,
but fuck,
just homeless,
stabbing festivals and you're from
four.
That's I,
yeah,
but that's a perfect example of like,
the energy that he stuff that.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like,
ah,
I don't.
Yeah.
But I do try to,
you know,
sometimes it does make me think twice before knee jerk go and fuck that shit.
That sounds retarded.
I'm like,
well wait a minute.
What if I do like,
I don't know.
Let's fucking live a little and see what fucking happens.
You know,
I'll go do some weird backyard show or I'll get in a car with some guy hires,
you know,
like after a show,
like,
all right,
I'll go to the fucking place.
You guys are,
you know,
like people want to hang out after the show.
Usually it's like,
I'm just going to walk back
some towns,
you know,
Austin's the best for meeting people and hanging out after the show.
I remember Brian,
we hung out with a dude who was born with no arms legs and he drove.
Oh,
that dude from the,
I know him from the Karaoke place.
Rob.
Yeah.
He's cool.
Very nice guy.
Yeah.
His friend in the runs man.
The crazy dude was his whole face tattooed and his tongue split down the middle.
He does like freaking enigma.
Puzzled to lizard man.
No,
that's another one that says another guy.
Yeah.
There's a lot of them,
man.
Wow.
That's a lot of it.
Through a lot of fucking crazy people that just go off with their face.
Yes.
Go Nani.
Put balt barbs in it and fucking horns and shit.
And I mean there's a photos online,
there's some photos online of people and be you ever seen the guy?
There's one really famous one.
He's got like,
he looks like a cat is going like cat face goes t sharpened,
everything's different colors has got giant ear plugs and all these different
lip piercings and nose piercings.
And he was a cat woman in Austin.
There's probably more than one,
but one from when I first moved there,
she had like whiskers fucking metal whiskers that she gets to screw into rice
and like tiger stripes tattoo.
Oh my God.
Is there pictures of her online?
I'm sure she was like married to or dating that enigma guy for out of the blue
guy with all the puzzle pieces in the horns.
Used to do the Jim rose.
I phone him Rodeos.
Shouldn't be too hard to
find a picture of her.
Yeah.
Austin Carrow,
Tiger woman,
Austin,
nothing.
Where are you performing tonight,
Brian?
Tiger Woods
Cat lady.
Maybe tonight I'm doing a show at the Improv lab.
Nice.
The improv lab.
It's cool man.
Yeah,
it's,
it
seems that once you get drinking it though,
that's the one thing I always bring beer in with me when I won.
I mean,
I don't know.
Can't you just get a beer from the other bar and bring it home?
They told me I wasn't allowed.
She have a tiger stripes all over her body.
Oh,
there's this bitch,
the crazy bitch.
Oh my God,
she's nuts.
Oh my God.
This crazy bitch.
What she did was she has these things and she's kind of cute and she had these,
uh,
at least from this lower resolution photo.
She's got tiger stripes,
like black stripes,
like tribal looking things all over her body,
all over her legs,
all over her arms,
all over her face.
And you can end the whiskers.
Yeah,
he's got these metal whiskers screwed into or fucking skull.
Whoa.
Sexy photo fucking shit.
Did I,
would you um,
no.
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean it's like if I met her and we were like hanging out and
I thought she was fun and I mean,
you would be down for fucking chick that has face tattoos.
I haven't,
but I mean I'm pretty open minded.
I mean it's like I'm not super,
uh,
I don't know what the word is.
Well,
no,
I'm just,
I'm super picky,
but I'm not as like aesthetically like,
it's not like,
oh,
I just need a blonde with big tits.
Like I can't,
I have to like,
like the personal if I'm going to,
yeah,
like if there's,
there are girls who like maybe weren't like super by,
you know,
general standards.
Like,
oh,
she's super hot,
but like I was fucking,
there was so much fun to hang out with and yeah.
I don't know.
Like,
yeah,
I'll have sex with girls if there's cool and if they're cool,
they're not like,
I mean,
yeah,
yeah.
If they have face tattoos,
that's like,
I don't know if I,
if that attractions there,
I can't really control
reminded how about this dude that's a champion.
Look at those.
Oh my God.
That's kind of like that.
Yeah.
Like I went deep.
I mean,
this guy he has,
if you haven't seen cat man,
you got to look it up.
The guy's name is Dennis Avner.
A V,
e,
n,
r and he's got everything,
man.
He's got fangs.
He has cheek implants.
He has like,
it looks like he's wearing some crazy contact lenses.
He's,
he's,
I don't know what he did with his teeth.
He's got some sort of dental things like a cap,
you know,
crazy cat,
but he just makes a living off of looking like that.
I mean,
that's fit.
It does man.
What does he do?
Work at a gas station.
Just could be some crazy person and he's a trust fund baby.
What's the name of that APP again?
It's called,
uh,
which one we're talking to?
The one that takes all your shit together.
Evernote.
Okay.
I want to say end gadget for some strange reason.
Gadget.
Uh,
that
trust fund kid who just wants to look like [inaudible] could be just some dude
is broken there.
I like that.
Did you,
have you,
have you been watching that celebrity rehab zoo?
This one kid now,
one of the kids is a billionaire's son,
really celebrity,
but he's the poor kids walked up on heroin and all kinds of shit.
Just,
he's just a physical wreck and just rebels.
Just chaos,
you know?
Yeah.
That could easily be a cat person.
The same shit.
I mean,
you just,
you start down that road.
Next thing you know,
you're screwing spikes in your fucking forehead.
Yeah.
Wish I was a trusted on kid.
Do you?
I know one,
he's a week condo of a man.
Just a shell and I don't say kinds of a man,
like he's a bad guy.
He's actually a nice guy and he has,
it has nothing.
He has no drive.
He has,
he's always got this idea of doing things and nothing ever gets done.
Every business venture
I have that I don't have a giant safety net.
He's got no care.
Yeah.
Just there's,
you know,
I think human beings need a certain amount of tasks and accomplishing those
tasks gives you confidence and that confidence gives you a better understanding
of yourself and your capabilities and what you can accomplish in this life.
And people who've never had to accomplish anything,
they've never had to pull her own weight.
They've never had to make something out of nothing.
They've never had to go out and achieve and get something done.
Those people who have no connection to life,
they're just adrift.
They're just loose and everything's come to them and they don't understand,
you know,
and then they,
they,
they just,
they have no purpose.
No meaning.
It's a,
it's a fucking,
it's a weird thing that we,
as,
as beings,
as human beings have to realize,
is that we have a certain amount of requirements.
We require physical touch.
We have to have it.
We have to be,
you'll be depressed if you don't have,
you know,
not even just sex,
but hugging and affection and being around loved ones like that's all required.
What's required of your biology?
You need to be able to blow out stress.
You have to,
you have to have some sort of physical exercise.
If you have a physical body,
your body is basically the same fucking hardware as people that live thousands
and thousands of years ago and needed to run away from wolves and to fight off
fucking,
you know,
angry tribes coming over the hill.
I mean,
there's a lot of shit that was required of our bodies back then.
It's basically the same hardware you've got to,
except all those things like people have to do in order to manage your life
correctly.
You really have to look at all those things and say like,
these are all requirements.
This is,
this needs to be met.
You know,
like priests going crazy.
You want to fucking kids,
Hey,
guess what?
Your body has a sexual requirement.
You've got to take care of it.
If you can't even masturbate,
yeah,
you're going to go nuts.
You're going to go nutty and stick it in anything warm.
You're fucking,
you're sick.
And that's what I was taught when I was talking about the nuns earlier when I
called them dikes around.
I don't have anything against dikes,
but it's,
that's what it was.
They're repressed.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
they can't,
you know,
they can't even rub one out without feeling dad about it.
Port Fox.
So instead they just screaming your kids' faces.
And the problem is once it religion gets started,
it's so fucking difficult to stop.
It's so easy to keep on going.
You know,
it's real easy to like for,
you know,
if,
if Catholics,
if it wasn't Catholic priests,
it wasn't like a certain percentage wasn't like 10% it was 100% of all of them
were raping kids.
100% of people would still argue for the Catholic church who would say,
but they do so much good work and they're so good with the homeless and they,
my sister is not pay to that part.
Let's just focus on,
even if there was 100% of them,
people are so committed to it that they would still,
there's still people who'd be willing to go to church.
Oh God.
Yeah.
I mean even it was 100% of all priests proven.
They all,
you know.
Right.
Don't you think cross the board so hard to stop.
One getting one started once they get started.
You know,
it's easy to like ridicule Scientology like,
oh my goodness.
It was remade by a science fiction author in the 1950s hot.
Isn't that better information than these fucking monkeys that wrote this shit
down on animal skins and they'll come on stupid.
Yeah.
I'll start a fucking religion.
We need to start a religion.
Steric divert difficult to start a new one though.
It's very hard.
You can look wherever we were looking at the,
um,
the pilgrimage around the mosque,
around,
um,
uh,
Mecca or see when there's a,
like this box like structure and they all walk around it and they all were like
traditional robes.
It's really crazy.
Yeah.
It's really strange to watch and know there's thousands and thousands of people
walking around.
But what I was saying,
when I,
when I first saw it,
I was like,
if this was new,
if this was a new religion,
wouldn't you be shitting your pants if all of a sudden there were some new
religion where everybody wore robes and they had a super secret box.
It was in the middle of Saudi Arabia and they all walked around it.
We would be for Rican.
The fuck out they would do would be 24 hour coverage on CNN.
They're still circling the box,
no word yet as to what's going on inside the box.
What does the box represent?
My,
well,
we're not exactly sure.
There's a unit,
there's different accounts.
Some folks say that's where Muhammad is buried,
and some say it's not.
It could be some sort of a sacred media.
Right.
And we would be terrified.
We would like Waco.
You know what I mean?
It's really like some new super Waco sort of a situation,
but because of the fact that it's been around a long time,
we just sort of accept it.
You know?
It's interesting,
man.
It's interesting.
We were,
we're cool with shit.
As long as it's always been like that.
Even if it's fucking ridiculous,
if it's complete total nonsense,
as long as it's already exists,
we sort of just go with whatever we see around us.
Like those ladies in Africa that,
that cut their lips and then stretch their lips calculates and,
and the larger the plate is just now,
finally in like 2009 2010 2011 finally hipsters,
they're starting.
Women are starting to not do that.
They are right.
Have you ever seen one person in America?
We have the plate lip lip plate.
No.
That's the way they do it in Africa.
It's a serious commitment.
Yes,
a smash out your bottom teeth and the women next stretching ladies too.
That's crazy man,
because you can't take that shit off.
Now thinking about that,
it's an Africa.
How hot is Africa?
Hot and sticky and sweaty and bugs are in those little metal bars and dirt and
fucking stray loads because you're a girl for sure.
Some straight loads made the way to that metal.
Right?
If you're some crazy African lady with the long neck for sure.
Want to do it is thinking I am going to face fuck this shit out.
This bitch.
Look at all that neck.
She just swallowed my Dick.
No problem at all.
So there's all that and you can't even take them off to wash them because if you
take them off your head where your head will fall right off,
he'll die.
Break your spiders.
So shit,
people are nuts.
Speaking Africa stuff.
I just noticed the trilogy of terror doll.
Yeah,
I got that from Bobby Slayton.
Oh yeah.
Bobby Slayton had one of the first Internet radio shows long before the Joe
Rogan experience podcast back in the day.
Bobby Slayton.
There was some,
some weird company that was trying,
I mean,
this is like the 90s,
they were trying to create a,
an Internet radio station because people have the radio at work and you could
listen while you're at work or whatever.
And so they hired a bunch of comics and I forget what it was called,
but they,
uh,
you know,
Bobby Slayton had the best show on it and he had,
like,
it was basically the Bobby Slayton show,
but it was on,
you know,
on the Internet.
It'll tell you ahead way,
way,
way ahead of its time.
And bandwidth was like super expensive and dial,
couldn't figure it out.
Yeah.
They figure out a way to,
you know,
to,
to monetize it.
I think,
you know,
I think I was using dial up up until like 2000 really again with the whole,
like,
I'm not technologically,
I don't give a shit like 2000,
2011.
I love him.
And that wasn't easy.
I was probably using dab up in 2000 until you're really worried.
It seems like 2000,
2000,
2001,
2000.
I had
uh,
definitely had,
not I,
I might've had ISD in 2000.
No,
no I didn't.
I had to take one line at a t one line
cause I couldn't get,
couldn't get ISD in up here.
Oh I couldn't get,
rather I couldn't get cable and I couldn't get DSL so I got a t one line until
they get DSL up here.
So I had some ridiculous Internet connection up here.
Like a business connection that you use for like an office building
I had to get,
it was the only thing I could get.
It was high speed.
That was my a game addiction days dude,
for sure.
For sure.
They're coming up with this new way of broadcasting,
wireless Internet that that goes through light spectrums.
Have you heard of this?
I've heard of it.
Wow.
Just like how wireless Internet goes through radio spectrum.
This goes through a light spectrum.
Wrap your fucking head around that.
They're their wireless Internet through life,
but you knew what you already have.
We know you can do Internet through power lines,
you know,
power line adapters and stuff like that.
So there's nothing really too crazy.
It's just like you have,
you plug in,
one plug is your internet and then you know on the other side of the house you
have the other side of the Internet.
It just runs through your power lines.
Brendan Walsh was tickled.
I have to Piss.
So yeah,
I've been,
I could see it.
I can see the way you're moving fella.
Well,
an expert on shit to 45 just saying.
Should we just wrap this pitch out?
He's probably just around this rap as Bishop Brennan.
Where is it?
Where can people see you next man?
Uh,
tonight at the Improv lab tomorrow.
What time does the Improv lab,
I think the show starts at eight 38 30.
And then tomorrow we'll be on the eight o'clock show at the Improv.
And if you're in New York,
I mean you go to my website,
Brendan walsh.com.
B R e n d o n w a l s.
H.
A.
And I'm going to be taping
a couple episodes of the John Oliver show.
What's that work?
So you know the guy from the daily show,
John Oliver,
the English dude.
Okay.
Correspondent.
He has,
he's a stand up and he has his own stat.
It's like John Oliver and friends.
So you come down to host this show and then there's like four comics come out
and do like 10 minutes.
Is this a comedy central show?
Comedy Central.
Yeah.
And there is,
if you go to my website,
there's a link.
If it's this week,
this coming weekend,
uh,
the 14th 15th and 16th you can,
there's a link on my front page where you can go get free tickets.
If you want to go to the taping.
It's on the Nyu campus and then I'll be in a good way.
Bananas and Cincinnati.
February 10th,
13th and a Sun Valley,
Idaho.
I think I did go bananas in Cincinnati.
I'm pretty sure I did.
You say Cincinnati is a weird one,
didn't I?
I didn't know.
I don't think it was go bananas.
I think you did the clubs.
Doug,
I know work you did with Ra.
There was,
cause there was a a a show there once there was a UFC in Cincinnati is a weird
place.
We have to land in Kentucky and they called the Cincinnati airport.
It's in Kentucky.
Yeah.
That's trip.
And that's the a Cincinnati funny bone is actually in Kentucky.
They call it the one that we would not be fulfilling.
Yeah.
I went to go bananas to once power.
There's a long Benson's favorite [inaudible] some reason it's a really small
club man.
Yeah,
it's,
it's uh,
yeah.
I don't know what it holds too.
It's like a basement sort of a,
yeah.
It's got a crucial,
I mean the name go bananas doesn't do it justice.
I did it with Chris Mcguire.
That's how I did it with Brian Long ass time ago.
And then the next time I came I did the funny bone.
Cool.
I think,
fuck am I talking about February 10th through 13th I'll be at the funny bone and
uh,
yeah,
the New York thing.
Go to my website.
I teach Connolly's gentleman shows coming up.
I got a the Improv in Miami or not Miami.
I ain't going there.
Sorry.
The improv in West Palm Beach,
Florida.
That's where I'll go on.
Um,
west palm beaches,
a 28th,
29th and 30th and,
uh,
February 4th at the Mandalay Bay theater in Vegas.
You dirty bitches.
That one is a,
that's going to be a good one.
That's Ari Shaffir and Joey Diaz.
If Joey Diaz doesn't pull a Joey Diaz.
Yeah.
Like you did the other night at Sal's.
We were all at Sal's.
Brendan was at sales as well,
and Joey was supposed to go up and do a set and he just fucking [inaudible]
tweeted tonight.
Cocksucker listen,
cock sucker.
Those things,
they go,
shit happens.
I'm a loyal soldier.
Cock sucker you to do what I gotta do.
He's Joe Diaz,
man.
Just,
he just sometimes he pulls the Jody is just doesn't want to,
I don't know him super well,
but I hear about him a lot from diabetes.
A fucking national treasure.
Funniest,
funniest man ever walked the face of the planet.
No one's closed.
No one's made me laugh as hard.
I'll show you a video once we get done with this,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's it.
Show's over.
Thank you.
Uh,
to the flashlight flashlight.
Rather,
if you go to a Joe rogan.net and you click the link and uh,
you could get
a fleshlight for 15% off your enter in the code,
the code is Rogan and it's,
you get a discount,
a discount on your massive batory tool,
and I do support it.
It's a fucking excellent product.
Gives you massive ball twitching orgasms.
If you can get past the fact that you're fucking or rubber vagina,
you're a grown man.
This is what you chose to do with your time.
Pass that.
That's fucking awesome when you're taking it and when you're loading it in the
dishwasher,
we will have another podcast on Thursday.
We're not exactly sure who's going to be there.
We've got a couple of options.
We're going to figure that shit out.
So we'll have another one of these on Thursday and of course you iTunes freaks,
you don't care.
You'll get it when you get it.
You don't really get it@thesametimeunlessyougotojoerogan.net.
You can always download it right away.
Right after the,
we do it Tuesday and Thursday.
It's always available online.
I'm talking too much and I'm tired of sound of my own fucking voice.
I can.
Good bye.
Good bye everyone.
As always.
We love you bitches.
[inaudible].